a language crafted by the Brilliant
Minds at Sun Microsystems led by James
Gosling has emerged as a programming
giant captivating developers worldwide
its charm lies in its Simplicity and
portability making it a favorite among
developers Java's platform Independence
is a game changer with its right ones
Run Anywhere principle you can create
applications that effortlessly adapt to
Windows Mac OS Linux and even embedded
systems Java empowers you to unleash
your creativity without limitations
imagine a world where you can build
robust software that runs seamlessly on
any device or platform a world where
your code Comes Alive powering
applications that revolutionize
Industries and enhance everyday
experiences welcome to the world of Java
programming so here I am with another
video by simply learn where we'll
discuss the basics of one of the most
popular programming languages Java but
before we begin with the video if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
get notified whenever we drop a new
video
so let me take you through the reasons
why you should learn Java in 2023 not
just one but there are multiple reasons
why Java is so popular and worth
learning in today's world
wide range of applications Java is The
Versatile programming language used in
various domains such as web development
mobile app development enterprise
software development scientific research
and more learning Java opens up
opportunities to work on diverse
projects and industries platform
Independence one of the key strengths of
java is its right ones Run Anywhere
capability Java program can run on any
platform with a Java virtual machine
installed making it highly portable this
platform Independence allows you to
develop applications that can be
deployed on different operating systems
without significant modifications robust
and mature ecosystems Java has a vast
ecosystem with extensive libraries
Frameworks and tools that simplify and
accelerate development libraries like
spring and hibernate Frameworks like
Java FX and play and Powerful integrated
development environments like IntelliJ
and Eclipse provide developers with Rich
resources to build robust and scalable
applications object oriented programming
Paradigm Java is an object-oriented
programming language which means it
encourages modular reusable and
organized code by learning Java you gain
a strong foundation in oop Concepts like
encapsulation inheritance and
polymorphism which are fundamentals to
many modern programming languages this
knowledge can be transferred to other
group languages making learning and
working with them easier strong job
market Java has consistently been in
high demand in the job market many
organizations rely on Java for critical
applications leading to a constant need
for skilled Java developers learning
Java can enhance your employment
prospects and provide you with a stable
career path according to glassdo the
average salary of a senior Java
developer can go up to 9.5 lakhs per
annum with additional cash benefits the
same Java developer can earn up to 116
000 annually in the United States these
figures clearly reflect the high value
placed on Java skills in the industry
today so are you ready to take your
career to new heights the demand for
full stack web developers is soaring in
today's fast-paced world and now simple
learn presents the perfect opportunity
for you to excel in this exciting field
without post graduate program in full
stacked web development this
comprehensive program will equip you
with the foundation to build full stack
web applications using the power of Java
programming language from the basics of
JavaScript to advanced level Concepts
like angular spring boot hibernate jsps
and MVC we have got you covered what
else can you expect from this program
this program includes Caltech ctme
postgraduate certificate enrollment in
simply learns job assist receive up to
25 CEUs from Caltech ctme simply learns
job assist help you get noticed by the
top hiring companies you'll also get to
attend master classes from Caltech ctme
instructors live virtual classes led by
industry experts Hands-On projects and
integrated Labs online convocation by
ctme program director 20 lesson and and
five phase and projects so let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers
learning is growing and we not only
decided to grow together in life but
learn and succeed together as well I
successfully special
Java domain with a
with a salary hike and I was able to
grab new opportunities in my current
organization and also receive a 10
salary hike hey I am swamijit Basu I am
a senior QA engineer at Encore Inc
identally we made the right choice after
our marriage I had to relocate to
Bangalore and take a year Gap after
working 45 years but I decided to
restart my career again and make a
switch to software domain so I enrolled
myself in full stack Java developer
program from Simply learn seeing my
wife's passion for learning every day
inspired me to take up a course on
simply learn as well I've always been
passionate about technology and learning
devops was always in my bucket list when
I saw simply learns collaboration with
Caltech ctme I decided to take a course
on PG devops after the course I not only
switched my career to full stack Java
development with a 15 increment in the
salary but now also I can work from home
since it's a software domain and being
the new mom that's the best thing one
could ask for to spend time with little
one during these early years
for me learning devops was fun and
fulfilling at the same time earlier I
had to rely on others at work but after
upskilling myself I single-handedly can
set up the entire blueprint on my code
base alone and get the desired output
and because of that I could grab new
projects in my organization with a 10
percent salary high we enrolled to
upscale ourselves when we were expecting
our first child so upscaling Journey
with simply learn would be undoubtedly
very special to both of us while doing
the course we did come across a lot of
challenges due to the pregnancy but my
wife show me was a great inspiration for
me as she was handling it all together
and she kept motivating and inspiring me
all the way moreover the recorded
classes and the weekend class helped us
maintain the balance between work and
learning apart from work we love to
spend time with our little one learning
with simply Learned was quite a
fulfilling experience for both of us we
believe that growth doesn't happen
overnight rather it's a journey of
several small steps and upskilling is
one of them so let's take a look at what
we are going to cover in this video
we'll start this video with the history
of Java programming where we'll get to
know who and why created Java following
that we'll give you an introduction to
Java programming once we are done with
this we'll start with the most basic
concepts of java like data types in Java
operators in Java and Loops in Java once
we are done with these Basics we'll move
on and cover objects and classes in Java
following that we'll cover topics like
arrays and strings in Java programming
once we are done with all these topics
we'll cover the object oriented
programming concepts of java where we'll
cover abstraction encapsulation
polymorphism and inheritance in Java so
it is rightly said that you can Master a
programming language only by programming
in it so towards the end of this video
we'll work on a project where we'll
create a calculator app using Java
programming so I hope you guys are ready
to learn the basics of java so without
any further delay let's hand over this
session to our training experts James
Gosling and colleagues at Sun
Microsystems develop Java in the early
1990s this team of Engineers call
themselves The Green Team and initiated
the project for interactive television a
typical example of interactive
television would be the real time voting
on the screen in which the user can
control the show however this technology
was too advanced for the industry and
was better suited for the World Wide Web
Java was initially named the green top
and then as Oak in 1994 it was
officially renamed to Java the first
public implementation was Java 1.0 in
1995. in 2006 some released Java virtual
machine as a free and open source
software in the same year j2se was
renamed as Java standard edition or SE
major releases involved Java sc6 in
March 2006 and Java se8 in 2014. as of
today Java 8 and Java 11 are identified
as long-term support versions popular
Java based products like junit Eclipse
Hadoop and Android revolutionize the IT
industry the biggest internet company
Google has a huge percentage of its
development in Java Accenture is using
Java for most of its clients Hardware
companies like Intel semantic Philips
Thomson are all Java users Java is also
considered the official language for
Android development pubg the latest
youth obsession is a cross-platform game
that uses Java as a sourcing language
since 2007 Java has remained a de facto
standard and is controlled through the
Java Community process
Java has evolved to become the most
popularly used language and continues to
make remarkable contribution into the
field of technology and when we talk
about the usage of java you can use it
to build web applications mobile
applications desktop applications even
command line applications and at the
same time you can also use it to build
complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing Etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's an object-oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in Java happens
around objects objects enable the
execution of the program objects talk to
each other to exchange data and messages
we will okay about a look at the concept
of objects in details in the upcoming
lectures it's a platform independent
language which means that again going
back to the previous point of write once
run any where it basically enables the
program to be run on any platform once
compiled so once you have prepared your
program and you have compiled your
program then your compiled program can
be run on any platform it is a strong
type checking language which means that
it will force you to respect the
contracts of the variables to the data
types for example if you have created a
collection which should accept strings
then you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly typed
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in Java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a Java compiler and you have a Java
interpreter you first compile your
program and then you run the program
using the help of java interpreter Java
also provides automatic garbage
collection it's a really important
feature and if you talk about the
languages prior to Java like C or C plus
plus they did not offer this capability
and this capability made Java really
popular because it could automatically
find the unused objects and variables
and remove them from the memory to free
up memory space for the program
execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so there's they can be one
thread which is monitoring your
leaderboard score there can be another
thread which is displaying the speed of
the car there can be another thread
which is displaying the graphic there
can be another thread which is
displaying the sound so you see all of
these threads are working parallelly and
Java provides the support to create such
applications using the multi-threading
capability it has Java is secure by
default because there are no pointers in
Java so there are no possibilities of
having any memory leaks or any reference
leaks from the application again if you
take the example of programming
languages like C or C plus plus you had
the concept of pointers and we we
witnessed lot of a lot of scenarios and
lot of incidents where there was a
memory leakage happening in the in the
production application which was which
was really a bad experience for the
organizations so Java removed the
concept of pointers totally from its
programming language it's also a very
robust language because it provides a
really great exception handling
framework out of the box which
developers can use and Implement to
build really resilient applications so
now let us understand how a Java program
is run so at first you basically write
your Java program and you store your
Java program into a DOT Java file then
you compile your Java file with the help
of the Java compiler once the program is
fight the compiler is going to generate
another file which is a DOT class file
and this dot class file is basically the
compiled file or also known as the byte
code file so this byte code or the dot
class file code can be run on any
platform be it a Linux platform or a
Windows platform or a Mac OS platform or
any other platform to give you some more
context the first two steps where you
write your Java program and you compile
your Java program can be run on any
machine let's take the example that you
ran these two steps on a Windows machine
so you add your you write your program
and you compile your program on a
Windows machine which generated a DOT
class file then you transported this dot
class file to a Linux machine and it
also worked there you transported your
dot class file to a Mac OS machine and
it worked there as well and that's what
brings the platform Independence concept
of java that you can write the program
once on any platform and once you have
the byte code available then you can run
this program on any other platform of
your choice okay so that was about how
the Java program execution works and how
the platform Independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download Java and install Java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the Java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for Java development
kit so the Java development kit is the
installation of the Java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or Java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like Java
runtime environment or JRE Java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other support voting libraries so
let us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the Java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can run that dot
class file using GRE in fact if you just
run your program on your local machine
JRE will automatically kick in and run
your dot class file so the Java runtime
environment or GRE runs your dot class
file with the help of these three
components let's talk about first
component which is Java virtual machine
or jvm so the Java virtual machine is
actually the virtual environment inside
which your program runs this is the real
main environment inside your dot class
file is running so when uh when this
program is running how does it achieve
this environment for achieving this
virtual virtual machine environment it
would need some runtime libraries and
that is provided by these class
libraries for example there would be a
runtime jar or rt.jar as a shorthand
which will be supplied to the program at
the runtime to make sure that the
program runs smoothly then there are
other supporting libraries as well which
your program may be using for example if
this program this dot class file is
let's say a calculator program then it
might be using a square root function
from java.math package so how do how
does the java.net package gets supplied
at runtime it would be supplied by the
other supporting libraries which are
present inside GRE so GRE will make sure
that your program runs inside the Java
virtual machine it gets the required
runtime Library series and it also gets
the libraries which are referred in your
program at runtime and this all together
will make sure that your program is
running so you can see jdk basically
provides GRE automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
GRE separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a Windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
install the GRE you don't install jdk
there you just install the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment so now let's download Java
let's go to Google and search for Java
download we'll go to the link we see
here oracle.com so now here we have the
web page here we can see Java se13 so
this is version 13 but this isn't the
one we are going to download we're going
to download the eighth version version
8. which is here now we're doing this
because 8 is one of the more commonly
used versions of java so let's click
this and here we'll go down we need to
accept the license agreement before we
can download it
now we have two versions here x86 and
x64. now you can download it depending
on what version your operating system is
now if you do have a Windows 10
operating system it's highly likely you
have a 64-bit version of Windows now if
you do have a 32-bit version of Windows
you can take the x86 so let's download
this
so we've actually already logged in so
we just need to run the installer file
now let's go to downloads
and run the file
so here we have the installer we go to
the next step
we'll select this to next here we can
see where the file is being installed to
we'll go to next
now if you want to change where you want
to install Java we can press the Change
option I'm just going to keep it here
we'll press next and let's commence with
installation
and there we go the installation is now
complete so we don't need any tutorials
or API documentation so we'll just
finish off and go to close
now to see if Java is installed in your
system we can go to command prompt
and type the term Java C which refers to
the Java compiler
now as you can see here this shows a
number of different options you can
choose from this also indicates that
Java has been successfully installed in
your system now if the installation was
not successful you'll see something like
Java C is not recognized as an internal
or external command operable program or
batch file but since we've done it
successfully this is what will be shown
now
and now we're going to set an
environment variable now what exactly is
an environment variable now assume you
have a file which has a Java extension
this environment variable tells the
computer that the Java program needs to
be called to run this particular file
so to set the environment variable we'll
need to go to control panel
here go into system and security
go to system and select Advanced system
settings and then this shows up now
before we go into environment variables
we'll need to go to where the Java file
was installed so let's go to this PC C
drive
program files and here let's go to Java
so let's go to jdk which is the Java
development kit let's go to bin here
and copy this path
we'll go back to environment variables
select path here
and then press on new
paste this and okay now we'll go back
and go to JRE to the path of GRE which
is Java runtime environment if you click
on this then again
and copy this path
select this one
new
and paste that
and there we go the environment
variables are now set
now let's talk about running that simple
program I told you about now this is
possible with the help of an IDE an IDE
or integrated development environment
will give us a platform to code Java we
will be using eclipse and IntelliJ as
they are popular and commonly used that
being said there are several other Ides
that are available in the market so now
let's work with Eclipse let's go to
Google and search for eclipse
go to this link
press download and then this shows up
let's click on download
now we've already downloaded the
software so I'm just going to directly
go into the install phase
downloads and select Eclipse with this
you can see that there are multiple
options for you to choose from so we're
going to select Eclipse IDE for Java
developers now you have other options
like for CNC plus plus JavaScript PHP
and so on let's go to the first one and
here you have the details you can change
them if you want but I'm just going to
go ahead with installation now
press accept now
here we remember accepted licenses and
press accept
and then here as well we'll remember
accepted certificates select this one
and accept selected
and there you go the installation is now
complete let's click on launch now
so here we are setting up a directory as
a workspace uh I'm not changing it here
so I'm just going to go with launch
here we have the eclipse workspace now
let's close this first and here we have
the package Explorer now in case this
doesn't show up you can go to window
Show view
and select on package Explorer so now
let's go to file
new and Java project we need to set up a
project name I'm going to call it my
project
one
click next we'll go to source so this is
where the source code for your program
is going to be stored then let's finish
and now we'll click on my project one
go to source I click new and create a
class we'll clean I'll name the class my
class
and create it and here we have it so now
let's write a simple program to multiply
two numbers
so now let's write the main function
open
bracket
now we're going to initialize the first
number
the second one
and finally the output
and finally the variable that will store
the output
now we'll just give them a simple print
statement
okay
now let's run The Code by clicking this
option here
using myclass.java and there we have it
here the product is shown to be 100
indicating that the program is running
successfully
now we're done with Eclipse now let's
move on to the other idea I was talking
about which is IntelliJ so for that
again we'll have to go back to Google so
that we can download it
search for IntelliJ download go to this
link here so here you can see that we
have two options the ultimate edition
and the community version now here the
ultimate version has way more options as
you can see here but it's a paid version
and only has a free trial now the
community version is free so that's what
we're going to take so we'll click on
download here so I've already downloaded
the software so I don't need to do it
again
so I'm going to go downloads and so here
we go let's just click on next select
the location where you want to install
it press next now we will add a 64-bit
launcher shortcut on the desktop
and create Association so basically this
means that these are the different file
extensions that this will support so dot
java.gui and now let's go to the next
step we'll install now and we'll wait
and there we go the installation is now
complete let's not import any settings
we'll accept the privacy policy we'll
set defaults
now let's create a new project so here
make sure your project SDK is set to the
version of java you've installed make
sure this isn't blank we will go to next
here you need to select this option
which is the create project from
template and we are now going to create
a command line application
press next
name the project which I'm going to call
my Approach
to
you can change the location if you want
I'm just going to keep it the way it is
and then click on finish
so now we're going to create a simple
program through which based on the
user's input we can determine whether a
number is even or odd so first we're
going to import the package scanner
through which we can take the user's
input
next let's go inside here let's create
available reader
now let's ask for the user's input
enter a number
we're taking in the value now
in the variable num
reader
dot next int
so this is with which we'll be taking in
the value from the user
so we're going to set up a condition to
determine whether the number is even or
not
so if the number
and when divided by 2 provides the
remainder 0 it indicates that it's an
even number
show them then
for the else case
okay
the number is not even
or in this case odd
there we go
we're done so let's run this program
so let's enter 12
the number is even and there we go we
have a successful output this indicates
that the program is running successfully
so let's learn about the data types now
so Java has these primitive data types
which you can see here some of them
store numbers some of them store Boolean
values and some of them store characters
so the data types which store numbers
are byte short int long float and double
these six data types basically are used
to store any kind of numeric value let's
understand these a bit more byte is the
shortest possible data type value which
you can use in Java to store numbers you
can only store numbers within the range
of minus 128 to plus 127 so you can see
the range is very small and Java has
created this variable for use cases
where you want to store numbers which
are very small value in this range why
do we provide these kind of options just
to save memory because the smaller data
type will require less memory to be used
in the Java program similarly the next
big data type is short which is a bit
bigger than byte and the range of this
particular data type where variables
will range from
-3 to 678 to plus three to seven six
seven so that is the range for this
particular variable and you can see that
it has a it has a very big range as
compared to the byte data type so if you
want to store very values which lie in
this range you can use short the next
one is int data type you can use this
one to store even larger values which
range from minus 2 raised to power 31 to
plus 2 raised to power 31 minus 1 the
next one is long which is even bigger
than int and it can be used to store the
values within the range of minus 2
raised to power 63 to plus 2 raised to
power 63 minus 1. so as you can see as
we go from top to bottom from byte to
Long the size of the value which can be
stored using this data type increases
and that's how you will basically take a
decision of whether you want to use byte
or you want to use short or int or long
based on what size of the value that
variable is going to contain then the
next ones are float and double these two
have been created for the use cases
whether where you want to store the
values numeric values which have
decibels which are Precision values I
should also mention that byte short int
and long are only used for storing
absolute numbers which do not have any
decimal representation even if you try
to store a decimal value in these
variables they will automatically be
trimmed the decimal values will
automatically be removed and you will
only be shown the absolute values and in
case of float and double they can
maintain those precision and decimal
values so we use float for the use cases
where you want to store decimal
representations of the values and you
can see that the float value can store a
smaller Precision value but double can
store even a bigger Precision value so
if you have really big Precision values
to be maintained very big decimal values
to be maintained we should use double
and the float is used for storing a bit
smaller size of the Precision values I
mean its range of values basically
beyond the scope of this discussion if
you want to read more about this you can
go to this particular links which will
explain this in detail but the basic
idea is that float is good for storing
two Precision values and if you want to
go beyond that you want to use double in
some cases some people also use float to
store even Beyond two values as well so
it completely depends the main the
decision factor is how long the value
you are going to store in the decimal
and that will be take the decide whether
you want to use float or double the next
one is Boolean which is used for storing
the Boolean values Boolean values can be
either true or false so there are only
two possible values and then we have
care which is used for storing
characters it is using 16 bit to store
the value and this is a very popular
Java question for beginner level
programmers that why does it store it
needs 16 bit to store the character it's
because it stores a Unicode
representation Unicode representation is
the representation which can be accepted
across platforms across the world in
different character encodings so let's
move on to Eclipse now where I have
prepared a very short and simple demo I
am just creating a variable for each
data type and I'm printing them you also
see some things here like the these
keywords and don't worry about these
keywords I will cover these keywords in
detail in the upcoming lectures you also
see this and you can just for now you
can remember that system dot out dot
println is used for printing anything in
Java anything you want to print on the
console you would be using
system.out.println what is system what
is out and what is println again we will
cover these in the uh upcoming lectures
for now I'm just creating a bunch of
data types here variables here basically
I'm creating a cap type variable a byte
type variable a short type variable an
in-type variable a float type variable a
double and a Boolean the way you create
variables is basically you put the data
type name you put the variable name
which can be anything you put an equal
sign and you put the value actual value
which this variable is going to store
and I've done the similar thing for all
of these variables Java wants semicolons
to be there when you write your
statements so please remember that your
statements always end with semicolons so
I've declared all of these variables
here a byte a short and int float double
and Boolean and then I'm printing all of
them basically here I am printing the
care variable here I'm printing the byte
variable here I'm printing the short and
so on so forth so how do we actually run
this application or this program we just
double click on this or right click on
this you go to this run as option you
see this run as Java application option
so you can hit this option it will run
the application and it will present all
the output here in the console tab let
me just bring this up so you can see all
the variables have been printed here and
this is coming from these print
statements like I said this is used
system.out.println is used to basically
print anything and I've used that to
print all the variables here first I'm
printing the care variable whose value
is a then I'm using the byte variable
which is denoted by B and whose value is
2 so you can see the value is 2 here
then I am printing the third variable
which is C which is a short type
variable which has a value 22 you can
see short and this is coming here the
next print statement is int so you can
see int here with the value 45 and this
value is coming from here then we have
float we can see the float value being
printed here and you can see the float
value declared here you also see an F
here and this is the standard naming
convention with Java proposes that
whenever you declare float and double
you end them with f or D based on
whether it is float or it is double then
you see the double value which is having
which is having a bigger position than
float so I have printed the double value
using this particular print statement
which is printed here and then we have
the Boolean value which is stored as G
and the value of G is true and the same
value is printed here so whatever I
write here basically is printed here
this is just a placeholder and this is
the actual value so you can see that we
are able to use all the variables here
all the Primitive variables basically
which range from byte character byte
short int float double and Boolean and
the first non-primitive data type we are
going to talk about is string and before
I go on further I should also mention
that it's very debatable in the Java
Community to call string as a
non-premitive data type and actually
technically speaking string is a special
data type it neither fully lies in the
Primitive category nor it fully lies in
the non-primitive categories I am
covering this as a non-primitive data
type because it's a bit inclined towards
the non-primitive category why do we do
this is because Java does provide native
support for string handling in the jdk
and that's the reason some of the
developers feel that string is a
primitive data type which is primitively
supported by Java but at the same time
string is so customizable and it's so
special in nature it's the way it's so
shows the value the way it provides the
operations and handlings it's so
different than primitive data types that
it cannot fully be put in the same
bucket as the primitive data types so
that's why I said it's it's a special
data type a bit inclined towards the
non-primitive category so what is string
basically we covered about the cad data
type in the previous lecture and in care
data type you can only store A Single
Character right but if you want to store
a complete name of somebody then it's a
list of character it's basically lot of
characters together then in that case
you would need a data type to store that
continuous sequence of characters and
that's what string does string can store
a continuous sequence of characters
technically string is basically a
character array you can call string as a
character array and don't worry if you
don't understand about the word array I
will explain that in the same lecture so
basically it stores The Continuous
sequence of characters
that's how that's how we Define string
and you see this string this is
basically the keyword the data type
basically in Java so whenever you want
to create a string you need to write
string with S capital you need to give a
name to the string this can be anything
and then you can provide the value which
is which this particular string is going
to contain so you can see this is a
continuous sequence of characters
t-e-s-t are the four characters which
this string is going to contain and
after that again I'm printing this
particular value and like I said don't
worry about this we'll cover this when
we'll when we'll write our first program
in Java so this is just to print the
string value I'm just putting a string
placeholder here and then I'm actually
putting the printing the values of the
string variable now string can be
created in multiple ways in Java this is
one way of creating it there is another
way of creating a string variable which
is this one which says again the string
data type some variable name a keyword
called new again don't worry about what
is this new keyword we'll cover this
when we'll talk about running our first
program in Java and writing the first
program from scratch then we again the
string and then we provide the value so
if I compare this line number four to
line number seven you can see the
differences that I'm still storing the
same value test but the difference is
that here there is no new string keyword
but here we have this new string keyword
so what is the difference the difference
is this that in this case in this
particular case string is going to reuse
the same object multiple times but in
this case every time you call this it is
going to create a new object again what
is object it's just you can think of it
as for now you can think of it as a
memory block we'll Again cover objects
in details but these are two different
ways in which you can create string this
is generally the most popular way of
doing it because this is memory
efficient because you can reuse the same
variable again and again so I'm creating
the string variable here and creating
another string variable str1 here and
printing both of them then I've created
this strange looking thing here which is
basically an array array like I said is
also an a non primitive data type in
Java and array can store a continuous
sequence of anything that anything can
be a number that anything can be
characters that anything can be or a
floating number as well so basic idea is
that if you want to store a collection
or a sequence of multiple multiple uh
values how do you do that you do that
with the help of arrays array is a data
structure a non-primited data structure
in Java which can store lot of values of
similar type we also call it as
homogeneous data structure which because
it can only store same data type values
a homogeneous data type values so the
the biggest way to identify array is
this Square bracket whenever you see the
square bracket in Java it means it's an
it's an array variable so here I am
creating an integer array variable with
the name ARR this is the name of this
particular array it is only going to
store integer values because of
specified int and the moment I provide
the square brackets its mean it means
that it is an array so you can declare
an array like this and then you need to
assign a size to the array size is
basically denoting how many values this
data structure is going to store so I am
saying new again it's a keyword and I'm
saying that okay create a memory block
for storing two integers so this
particular array ARR can store at Max
two values two values at continuous
locations the next thing about array is
that it stores the value in a zero index
based location so like I said it can
store two values so the first location
will always be array of 0 and this is
how you specify the location for index
of the element which is going to be
stored so at the zeroth location of this
array I'm storing 0 the first location
of the array I'm storing 1 and this is
just to show an error scenario but I
will just comment this for now you can
just put double slashes and comment any
line so I'm just storing filling up this
array for two values and the two values
location would be zero index and first
index these are just continuous memory
locations and we denote those memory
locations as 0 and 1 array indexes
always start with zero and I'm just
putting some values here you can put any
values and then I'm printing the whole
array and I'm also printing the first
value of the array and we'll see how
this pans out and we'll also see how we
can change this so now we are going to
run this application so I'll just go to
run as and click on run as Java
application and once I hit that I get
this output here so let's understand
this output the first one is I'm just
printing the string which has the value
test and you can see it has printed here
it is coming from this line then the
next line which is printed is line
number eight where I'm saying another
string str1 and str1 also had the same
value so you can see another string has
the same value and then I have printed
the array here the complete array and
you see this change value here it also
tells us that if you want to print the
array then you cannot just put the
variable name and print it the reason is
because this is a non primitive data
type and once you do this it is
basically printing the memory footprint
of this array the whole memory location
where this array is stored that's why
you see this strange looking number
which is the memory hash code and if you
want to print any particular value or
any particular element inside this array
then you can do that by providing the
index location of that element so here I
have said that print the 0th location
element of the array the zeroth location
array element of the array was zero so
you can see the value 0 here let me put
some other value just to just for fun
and show you how this works so just
change the values and now let's see what
do we get for array 0 we can see now I
get value 3 because now that at the
zeroth location the three value is being
stored and that is what is being printed
here we can also print the first value
I'll just go run as Java application you
can see now the array of first index is
being stored which is basically
technically the second element of the
array but because array always works on
a zero index based value format that's
why when we say array 1 the second
element is printed when I say array 0
the first element is printed so always
remember that array is a zero index
based collection or data structure
basically what happens if I do this now
there is no third element in this array
because the array has the size only of
two elements and when I say ARR of 2
which means I'm trying to print the
third element in this array which does
not exist so let's see what happens in
that case I get an exception exception
is basically an error I get an error
saying that index 2 is out of bounds for
length 2. it means that the array length
was actually 2 and index 2 does not
exist remember it's saying index 2 not
the element 2. index 2 doesn't exist
because only index 0 and index 1 exist
this makes two elements and the actual
size is also two it does not have
capacity to store third element it does
not have third element location anywhere
that's why it complains that you are
trying to print a non-existing value
when we talk about operators in Java
there are multiple types of operators
like assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what what these operators are and how
they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so when we talk about assignment
operators I have again opened the
official Java docs here if we understand
assignment operators we have been using
this operators all the while in all of
the demos so far and the basic idea is
very simple whenever you assign a value
to a variable you use the assignment
operator which is nothing but the equal
sign we have already covered this in
multiple demos so I will not cover this
as part of the demo but what I am going
to cover in detail is about these
arithmetic operators so arithmetic
operate letters are basically used to
perform any kind of arithmetic operation
on a Java program it can be an addition
operation it can be a subtraction
operation it can be a multiplication
operation a division operation or an
operation by which you can find the
remainder of the division so we will
look at each of these with an example
and as you can see the symbols are
expectedly what you generally use in
mathematics so you see the the plus sign
here which is for addition you see the
minus sign which is for subtraction you
see the star sign which is for
multiplication you see the slash sign
which is for division and you see the
percentage sign which is for finding the
remainder of our division so let's see
an example of each of these and how we
can use them in a Java program so for
the arithmetic operations I have
prepared a demonstration of it in the
Eclipse IDE again I'm using the same
Java project which I have shown you we
created in our previous lectures so I
will for all the demonstrations I will
just continue in the same project so
again the way to create a class Remains
the Same exactly the same as how I
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also I created a class I
named the class as arithmetic demo and I
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class and I have
basically tried to demonstrate each of
the operation so let's start with the
addition operation first so I create an
integer variable here named as result
and then I try to use the addition
operator to make this variable store the
result of this addition so it's a simple
one plus two you can also create two
different variables for one and two
let's say x equal to 1 and y equal to 2
and you can also do int result equal to
X Plus y it will have the same effect
but just for simple Simplicity I have
put the literal numbers here so result
is storing the the expression value of 1
plus 2 and then I'm printing this value
here you can see I'm printing the result
variable here with using
system.out.println then I'm storing this
result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then I'm trying
to subtract something from it so now I'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so I'm printing the
original result and then what I'm doing
that I'm again assigning the new result
which is 2 to the original result so now
original result and result both are 2
then I move ahead and I try to
demonstrate the multiplication operation
so I take the same variable result and I
say multiply it by 2. so whatever the
value of result was which at this place
should be 2 multiply that value by 2 so
2 into 2 the new value of result should
become 4 after this multiplication
operation and again I'm assigning the
value of original result to this
particular variable and then I'm
showcasing the fourth mathematical
arithmetic operation which is division
so you can see result by 2 here so
basically whatever the current value of
result is I am dividing that value by 2
so 4 divided by 2 should become 2 so
again the new value of the result
variable should become 2 then I am
printing the value and again storing the
value back into the original result then
the next operation is again an addition
operation where I whatever the value of
result is at this particular point which
is 2 and add 8 to that particular value
so the new result value becomes 10 and
then I'm printing that particular value
again assigning the original result to
the result and then to showcase the
remainder operation on doing result we
call this particular operator as mod or
modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is in this case would
be 10 so I'm saying 10 mod 7 so 10 mod 7
would become 3 because if we divide 10
by 7 the remainder should be 3 and this
modulus operator is used to calculate
the remainder of a division operation so
that 3 will be stored in this result
variable and then we print that
particular variable so that is what I am
doing if I take you back up there I will
just minimize this window and this
window as well so if I take you back to
the starting I am doing an addition
first here at line 7 then I am doing a
subtraction line 12 then I'm doing a
multiplication at line 17 and a division
at line 22 and then again an addition at
line 27 and then our modulus at line 32
and I'm printing the respective values
so let us run this program and see what
results do we get so I right click I go
to run as I go to Java application there
is also a shortcut for it if you want to
use the shortcut you can use that so I
click on this and the output is is
displayed here so you can see let me
bring this output back to its original
position yeah I just dragged it here to
the top to the bottom so if you start
from the top and see what all results
did we get printed so line 9 says 1 plus
2 equal to the value of result so 1 plus
2 equal to at this particular point the
result value was 3 because 1 plus 2
equal to 3. moving on the next variable
here is minus so the current value
reverse 3 we set 3 minus 1 which becomes
2 and we store the value of result or 3
into this result variable and we print
that value at line 14. so original
result plus original result is 3 then a
string here minus 1 equal to so this is
just a string and then the actual
current result value which is 2 so far
so good we move ahead and then at line
19 we are multiplying the current value
of result by 2 and again displaying the
original result and the current value so
2 is the original result here because
here 3 minus 1 had become 2 so original
result value was 2 multiply that by 2
becomes 4 then moving on to the line 24
2 by 4 by 2 should become 2 so 4 by 2
equals 2 the current value of result
then again moving on to the next
variable at line 29 now the result value
should become 10 because because 2 plus
8 is 10 and again we are printing the
original result and then the current
result value so the original result was
2 then we added 8 to it and the new
result value had become 10 which is
coming from this particular variable
moving on to line 34 we are again
printing the original result which was
10 here and then we are saying this
particular string which is modulus 7 and
the current value of result is coming
from this expression which is 10 modulus
7 and like I said modulus or mod
operation is basically used to calculate
the remainder of a division operation
which so 10 divided by 7 remainder is 3
so that becomes 3 and that's why you see
the value 3. so this is a demonstration
to show you how we can use the addition
multiplication subtraction Division and
modulus operators which are all the
arithmetic operators and I think this is
where we should stop this lecture so in
the next session we will be discussing
about the other are operator types which
are generally operators and we will also
discuss some other interesting operators
which are popularly used in Java so are
you ready to take your career to new
heights the demand for full stack web
developers is storing in today's
fast-paced world and now simple learn
presents the perfect opportunity for you
to excel in this exciting field with our
post graduate program in full stack web
development this comprehensive program
will equip you with the foundation to
build full stack web applications using
the power of Java programming language
from the basics of JavaScript to
advanced level Concepts like angular
spring boot hibernate jsps and MVC we
have got you covered what else can you
expect from this program this program
includes Caltech ctme postgraduate
certificate enrollment in simply learns
job assist receive up to 25 CEUs from
Caltech ctme simply learns job assist
help you get noticed by the top hiring
companies you'll also get to attend
master classes from Caltech ctme
instructors live virtual classes led by
industry experts Hands-On projects and
integrated Labs online convocation by
ctme program director 20 lesson and and
five phase and project so first of all
understand why do we need Loop
statements so generally whenever you are
dealing with some data structures in
Java which can store multiple elements
for example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple characters so
whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same then
in that case you would like to have a
way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if I want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using Loops coming to picture
now Java provides multiple constructs to
write Loops in Java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for Loop there is also an enhanced for
Loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular so there are multiple ways
in which you can actually iterate over a
collection and access all the elements
of the collection one by one and you can
use it to multiple useful cases for
example if you have a huge I of employee
salary and you want to give bonus to
each of the employees and add the bonus
to the salary then you need to do this
Edition for all the employees it would
be nice to have to return a while loop
and the while loop can automatically
access all the employee salary one by
one and keep adding the bonus to the
salary this would be an easier way to do
this rather than individually updating
each employee's salary and the first
Loop statement we are going to
understand is a while loop so the syntax
of while loop is very straightforward
you write the Y keyword you enter the
actual condition which will be
evaluating to a Boolean true or false so
you write the expression which will be a
Boolean expression exactly similar to
the conditions which you use to write in
your if statements so you write your
condition which will evaluate to either
true or false and then you write your
statement and these statements will keep
executing till the time this particular
expression evaluates to true so
generally the way it works is that it
will enter the while block it will
evaluate the expression if the
expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call the steps basically so it will will
go to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this Loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the IDE and look at an example of it so
I have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why will
we will we be using the while Loops so
I've created a while demo class I have
added a public static void main method
here which is the entry point I have
declared a variable which is int count
equal to one so the count value is one
right now and then I'm writing a
condition here I'm saying while count is
less than 10 do this so it will print
the current value value of count and
after that I'm using the post increment
unary operator if you remember we
covered this in the previous sessions
what is the meaning of this it basically
will increment the value of count by one
this expression is e is equivalent to if
I write it in this way if I write count
equal to count plus one this is exactly
the same as this no difference so this
will have the same impact I will just
remove this line because we already have
the count plus plus here so if we try to
understand this we are basically
incrementing the count and then checking
the condition again so at first time it
will be 1 less than 10 yes that is true
it will go inside and print the count
value the current count value which will
be 1 and then it does count plus plus so
now the count value becomes 2 it will
again go back here again check the
condition saying is 2 less than 10 yes
that is true so the while condition
again becomes true it will again go
inside this print the current value of
count which is 2 then do count plus plus
so it will again increment the value of
count so the now the count value becomes
3 again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the
three again go here make count as four
four less than 10 prints four again
count plus plus count becomes 5 and so
on so forth it will keep doing that till
the value becomes 10. so at a step when
count plus plus results in the count
value being updated to 10 it will go
here and say is 10 less than 10 now that
is not true because 10 is equal to 10
but 10 is not less than 10. so this
condition will become false and it will
exit of this while loop and it will come
here and it will execute if there's if
there was anything written after the
while loop that will be executed so
that's the idea that you want to do
something till a particular condition
holds true then you can use the while
loop Define your condition and execute
the statements and try to do something
which changes the state of this
condition here I am changing the count
so that every time a new evaluation
happens if I comment this this will
result in an infinite Loop because one
will always be less than 10 I will not
be incrementing the count here and it
will keep running forever it will never
stop it will just keep printing one one
every time till your computer program
runs out of the memory so always
remember not to end up into an infinite
Loop that's probably one of the biggest
mistakes any beginner programmer does so
please try to be aware of that
particular loophole not try to run an
infinite Loop always try to write
something in the code block which can
change the state of the condition and
also make sure that that state condition
sometimes sometimes should become false
you should also make sure that that all
that always becomes false because if I
do this if I do this then this condition
will always remain true because it is
already 1 then it will become zero then
it will become minus 1 minus 2 minus 3
so on so forth but that value of count
will forever be less than 10 and again
you will never be able to exit this Loop
your program will be stuck in this Loop
till your program runs out of the memory
so always remember to write a statement
or a statement of execution in your in
your code block which can change the
state of the condition which results in
some eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for one two three four five six
seven eight nine and that's it after 9
the moment the count plus plus resulted
into the count value becoming 10 it
checked that condition and then it just
came out of the loop because 10 is not
less than 10 and the condition became
false so always do something inside your
code block which results at least of one
scenario where this condition becomes
false and that is how you can use the
while loop now you can see this is a
pretty generic code and you can write
any kind of condition here write any
code you want to execute here and then
do something to change the state of the
condition as well in a positive way in a
way which results this particular
condition to be false at some point of
time and then your while loop will run
fine so this is all I wanted to cover in
terms of the while loop hello guys let's
get started with today's topic which is
about how to use do while Loops so let's
understand when do we need that and how
do you actually use that let me switch
to the Java documentation and if I can
find some syntax of it as well yep so as
you can see here if I just highlight
this portion this is how you actually
write a do while statement block so you
write do you start a code block you
write some executable statements and
then after the code block ends you write
a while X expression and end it with
semicolon this is the syntax basically
it starts with do or curly braces some
executable statements are while block or
a while statement basically with an
expression ending with a semicolon let's
understand this with the help of a
program to understand the structure
better so for this I have created a
sample program here which is called do
while demo again having a public static
void main method and it has a variable
which is count and it is initialized as
one then I write do I write this code
block or the curly braces and then I am
just printing the value of count then I
am incrementing the value of count and
then I am writing a condition which says
while count is less than 10 and
semicolon if you compare this with the
previous demo we ran if I just put them
side by side we had while condition
statement and and the state change
condition here that we have do statement
condition change statement and then we
check the condition at the end so the
idea is that if you have a use case
where before you even evaluate the
condition you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something in that case
you will use the do while loop even
before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
described here in this program so coming
back to the do while so I say do and
then I am saying print this particular
statement without checking anything this
condition will be executed for the first
time without any condition check at all
this will just work as is like a normal
Java statement after that I am
incrementing the the value of the count
and then I am checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment the first comparison
happened with the original value of
count but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count hope you get the difference in
a better context now that you will use
this when you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and will also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if I run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number nine again print
this again do an increment on the count
and again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say 3 less than 10 now similarly print
the value increment check this will
continue to happen till this particular
condition becomes false and once this
condition is false it will exit out of
this whole do while loop and it will go
to the line number 12 and if you have
any statement written there you can that
statement will be executed in this case
so let's try to change some values here
and let's see if if we can make sense of
this program if we change the value
let's see if I put 11 here what will
happen now let's run this program you
will say the now you will see that this
particular output is displayed which
says count is 11. so what happened here
that count was 11 it entered the do
while block it went to this particular
statement which said count is 11 then it
incremented the value so the value
became 12 and obviously 12 is not less
than 10 so it did not print it again it
only printed once even if the first time
the condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false still line number nine got
successfully printed and that's the
whole that's the whole idea behind using
the do while what if I change this value
to 10 let's see what happens and after
that we'll run one more combination to
just make it more interesting This Time
Again count is 10 line number 10 will be
printed as count is 10 then at line
number 10 the count is incremented to 11
and 11 is not less than 10 so in this
case the loop ends and it will move out
now what happens if I do this if I say
less than equal to here let's run this
program and interpret the output now
again only one statement is printed
because in this case the count is 10 10
is printed here and we are saying 10
plus 1 11 11 is still not less than
equal to 10 and that's why the loop just
exits let's make it 9 and see what
happens now you see two values so count
is nine it enters the do while loop goes
to statement number line prints the
current value of count which is 9 then
increments the value to 10 then at line
number 11 this while statement is
executed and the condition is checked is
10 less than equal to 10 yes 10 is not
less than but 10 is equal to 10 so this
condition will hold true it will go back
here print count is 10 May count 11
again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10 no it's not and then
the condition will return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we ran different permutations and
combinations of the values and we saw
when this will be executed and when this
will not be executed but the bottom line
is very straightforward that whenever
you want to write some pre-processing
logic even before checking the very
first condition of your Loop then in
that case you will be using a do while
loop otherwise a normal while loop or a
for Loop will have absolutely worked
fine hello guys let's get started with
today's topic which is about for Loops
in Java so so far we covered about while
loops and do while loops and we also saw
different examples of using different
types of data structures like arrays but
one of the core requirements whenever
you are working with any kind of
collection is to iterate over it exactly
similar to what I explained in the do
while and why lectures that you would
often require to iterate over a
collection or a data structure and for
that one of the most sophisticated and
easiest way to do that is using for
loops so let's understand the syntax of
for Loop first and then we will also
look at an example of it in the in the
Eclipse IDE so I have just opened the
official Java docs here so if you see
this is basically the syntax of a for
Loop statement so let's understand it
and let's also try to compare it with a
while loop so that we can understand how
it Compares with the while loop so if we
see the syntax we first see the term
initialization then we see the term
termination and then we see the term
called increment now if I try to compare
it with a while loop there also you
basically did these three things you
first initialized a variable outside the
while loop which is called
initialization and then you wrote a
condition which is your termination
condition you wrote a condition saying
let's say while I is greater than 10 or
while I is less than 10. so that is the
condition which is also the termination
statement the loop will continue to
execute till that condition evaluates to
false and that's when the loop
terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the I plus plus
which we used to do in the while Loops
so these three portions together make or
constitute any kind of loop in any kind
of programming language and for Loop if
you see the the kind of code which you
use to write in a while loop in multiple
lines where you first initialize a
variable then you write a condition in
the while block and then inside the
while block you used to increment the
variable all of that can be done in a
single line in the for Loop and that's
why I said it is the most sophisticated
and easiest way to write Loops in Java
so you write all of these three things
the initialization the condition and the
increment or decrement values in the
single line and then use start with the
curly braces and you write the code
which you want to keep executing till
the condition evaluates to false that's
the basic syntax of it so let us try to
understand this with the help of an
example so here I have opened a class
which is called for demo and this is a
class which will demonstrate the usage
of a for Loop so again we have a public
static void main method which you can
see here which is the entry point and
then I use the keyword for I put
standard braces for the brackets and
then I do the initialization so this
part is the initialization part you
initialize the variable so I just say in
time equal to 1 initialization done you
end it with a semicolon so that it is a
single statement understood by Java and
then you write this condition which is
your evaluation slash termination
condition so this condition is basically
the the deciding factor of how long your
Loop should run it's exactly similar to
what you used to write in the while blog
if I just show you the example this is
what we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while syntax or the construct
and then we did the increment here so we
are doing all of these three steps but
we are doing it in a single line so this
is the condition and then we write our
increment or decrement values which are
going to change the evaluation condition
every time at every step so we are
saying I plus plus so technically what I
am saying here is that start with i
equal to 1 and then check the condition
I less than 10 so in the in the first
step it will be checking if 1 is less
than 10 if the condition holds true go
inside the for Loop execute the
statement at line number seven and then
go back to this particular statement so
we do y plus plus so I becomes 2 and
then you again go back to the condition
and again you check if 2 is is less than
10 yes it is so again you go inside
inside the for Loop and do whatever is
written there there can be multiple
statements here for now I have just
written one system dot out dot println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
that's the increment so 2 plus 1 becomes
3 again does the evaluation exec and if
the if the condition holds true it will
again go inside so this will continue
this condition checking execution and
increment will continue till the time
this condition holds true the moment
this condition becomes false the control
will come out at line number nine so
that's the basic anatomy and control
flow it's very important to understand
the control flow of a for Loop otherwise
you might end up into a program which is
forever running and which will just heat
up all the memory available in your jvm
so be very sure of what you write in
your for Loop be very sure of especially
these two parts the condition and the
increment or decrement so this is very
important piece the initialization
happens only once and then this
condition evaluates if the condition
holds to True some code executes goes
back to the changing statement which can
be an increment to decrement whatever
and again compares the updated value
with the condition so this will keep
happening let's run this code to
interpret the output
so I will right click go to run as Java
application and if I interpret the
output here I can see that it started
with count is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and 9. it
stopped at nine so what happened there
let's try to evaluate the termination
condition so let's say I has become 9
and 9 is less than 10 so it goes inside
and it prints count as 9 which is I then
it goes here and it says 9 plus 1 I plus
plus means nine plus one the current
value of 5 plus 1 it becomes ten and
then it again compares the condition so
now 10 is not less than 10 10 is equal
to 10 but it is not less than 10 so the
condition becomes false and count is 10
is never printed because this condition
has become false it will jump out so
let's say if I do this if I put an equal
to here and if I now execute the same
program
this time I will see 10 here and because
I have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the I will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite Loops for
example if I say I equal to 1 I leave it
that and I say I minus minus so what
happens I equal to 1 1 is less than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then I decrement the value I don't
increment the value I decrement the
value so whatever value comes out will
always be less than 10 and this Loop
will run forever for fun let's try to
run this and I will I will have to kill
this program manually but just to show
you what happens and what you should not
do in your in your Java program so you
see it will continuously keep printing
the values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is it is forever running it
will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so I'm
just gonna kill the program but this is
something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing Java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers hello guys and let's get
started with enhanced for Loops in Java
we generally use the enhanced for Loops
for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for Loop and this for Loop is
even simpler like I said it's even
simpler than writing a classic for Loop
and the syntax is simply like this you
again start with for put the standard
brackets and then let's start from the
right most because then I will be able
to explain it better you specify the
collection in the right most side of the
bracket The Collection can be an array
it can be a list it can be a map so
whatever different kind of collections
which are available in Java and we are
going to cover collections in detail so
don't worry if you don't understand what
are lists and what are maps and what are
sets we will go into detail of each of
these one by one in the upcoming
sessions but the idea is that you put
the collection to the right most then
you put a colon and then you put a
representation of the member of this
collection so for example here this
numbers is basically an INT array so
this int array means that this array Can
Only Hold integer numbers and that's why
we write int here because this array is
only having integers then we put any
placeholder variable name this can be
anything you can even write it as I if
you want to you can write it as anything
any variable name which you want to
write this is a temporary variable so
now this code is going to execute in a
manner that it is going to iterate over
this array one by one starting from the
first element going till the last
element you don't need to write any
initialization code you don't need to
write any termination condition code and
you don't need to write any increment or
decrement code also and how these threes
how these three values are actually
taken care of let's understand that as
well so when we talk about the
initialization as I have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for Loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index 0 as
you know that array is a zero index
based structure then comes the condition
part so the condition evaluation is
going to be again based on the size of
the array or the size of the data
structure which you are using it is
going to start from the first index
which is the index 0 and it is going to
iterate till the array's last element is
reached so technically start from the
index 0 and go till the last element
that's your evaluation condition and
then comes the increment part so at each
step after it has successfully accessed
the first element automatically the
index is going to be updated to pointing
to the next element so if it starts from
here once the first step iteration is
complete I is automatically going to be
incremented to index 1 and then it will
basically this I will be holding 2 then
in the next iteration the same I is
going to be holding 3. similarly I will
keep holding the new value of the
collection item one by one till the
collection items last element is reached
so this is the basic premise that you
can write a collection variable here and
keep iterating over it and this whatever
variable you write here will hold the
current items value one by one so in the
first step this I is going to hold 1 in
the Second Step this I is going to hold
2 in the third step this I is going to
hold 3 and so on so forth that's the
basic idea so now let's run this program
to see what kind of output do we get so
you can see we basically are able to
print all the elements of the array and
that's probably one of the most popular
usage as well that if you want to just
print all the elements or access all the
elements of array or a collection one by
one then just use enhance for Loop so
you can see at each step it is printing
the value of I and the value of I is
basically the subsequent elements of the
array that's the whole idea with
enhanced for Loop under the hoods if we
talk about how does it work under the
hood it is actually using the classic
for Loop construct itself but for
developers it is making it easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection you will
start with the first element and you
will go till the last element so it
knows the initialization value the
termination condition and it also knows
the increment condition and that's the
reason you will use enhanced for Loops
in Java for iterating over collections
hello guys let's get started with nested
for Loops in Java so in front of you you
can see an example which I have prepared
for nested for loops and in this
particular example I have created a two
dimensional array as you can see on the
line number six I have created an
integer array and I have put two square
brackets here which are basically
symbolizing that this is a two
dimensional array so this two
dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d Matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for Loops
to to print this 2D array in a 2d Matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and call us clearly let's first try
to interpret this particular 2D array so
we have a curly braces outside and then
we have these three Inner Elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a 3
into 3 2D array which has three rows and
three columns so so we can say that this
is basically a 3 into 3 array which has
three dimensions on the row side and
three dimensions on the column side or
just a three by three Matrix or three by
three 2D array so as we know that in
case of arrays everything starts from 0
so technically if we talk about the
indexes it it would be the index 0 index
1 and index 2 on the row side and
similarly index 0 index 1 and index 2 on
the column side so that's that's
something which you should remember
because we are going to use this
particular concept when we write the for
Loop so let's try to write the for Loop
now if you look at line number eight we
put this keyword called for and then we
write the initialization so we say int I
equal to 0 then we are writing the
termination condition and we are saying
run this particular Loop run this whole
Loop which ends at line 13 till I is
less than 3 and keep incrementing I at
every step that's what I'm doing in the
line number eight then inside the for
loop I am writing another for Loop which
has another different variable called J
it can be anything you can name it
anything you want and this also starts
with 0 and this also has a similar
condition which is which says run this
particular Loop the line 10 basically or
this Loop which is signified by this
curly brushes run this particular Loop
till the time the value of J is less
than 3 and keep incrementing J at every
step and at line number 10 print the
element of array which has the current
value of I and the current value of J
these are basically the positions these
are not the elements the element would
be represented by this whole but print
the element which is at current I and
J's position values that's what this
code means so let's try to do a dry run
on this particular code to understand
how this is going to work so at first we
have I equal to 0 0 is less than 3 and
it goes inside it initializes J as well
with 0 and J is 0 is also Less Than 3 so
this condition went true that's why we
went to line number nine and line number
nine condition also went to true so we
went to line number 10. remember that in
this particular case at line number 10
the values of I and J are 0 and 0
respectively and we are saying print the
array of 0 and 0 so 0th rows zeroth
column element should be printed so this
is the zeroth row because this is the
first uh first sub block and this is the
first element so in this case in line
number 10 2 should get printed then it
goes here and it increments the J to 1
so 0 plus 1 becomes 1 it again checks
the condition is 1 less than three so
yes 1 is less than 3 it goes here
remember it did not go up at line number
eight it just came back from line number
nine so when it comes here I is still 0
but J has moved from 0 to 1. so now we
are trying to access the element which
is at zeroth row First Column which is
going to be 7 so 7 is going to get
printed similarly on the next iteration
J is going to get incremented from 1 to
2 and again the condition will be
evaluated so 2 is less than 3 all good
it will again come back to line number
10 and now it will say print the value
of 0 Row third or the second column or
the third element so zeroth Row Third
element which is the 9 so 9 will get
printed then again J will be incremented
and J will become 3 2 plus 1 3 and now
the condition will be evaluated is 3
Less Than 3 no it is not less than 3 the
condition becomes false so it breaks out
of the loop goes to line number 12
prints an empty line because we are not
writing anything here so it will just
print a blank line and now it will go
back to line number Eight's condition
and it will do an increment of I and now
I will move from 0 to 1 and now the
evaluation will happen is 1 Less Than 3
yes 1 is less than 3 so it will again go
to line number nine again initialize J
with a flash 0 the previous J got
destroyed the moment you came out of the
loop so this is a new J so this J again
gets initialized to 0 0 is less than 3
it goes here remember I was 1 in this
time so now it will print the value of
this 2D array which is sitting at 1
comma 0 basically second row first
element so second row first element
which is three again J is going going to
get incremented and it will become from
0 to 1 so 1 is less than 3 yes it will
again come here and it will print the
value of the array which is sitting at
array of 1 comma one for a row equal to
1 and column equal to 1 which will be 6.
similarly J will get incremented again
again 2 is less than 3 come back here
we'll print one then again we'll
increment J J will become 3 3 is less
than 3 no it's false the condition is
false so it jumps out of the the loop
goes to line number 12 prints a blank
line again goes back to 8 line number
eight increments I and I now becomes 2 2
is less than 3 yes it will again go here
initialize J again with 0 and again does
the same thing for the Row 2 and column
0 1 2 and again it will come out of the
loop this time again when it will go
here the value will become from 2 to 3
and 3 is not less than 3 so then it will
break out of the outer loop so the idea
is execute the inner loop for every
value of the outer loop remember this
line because that is how you will be
applying your knowledge of nested for
Loops to be used in certain condition so
whenever you have a scenario where you
have to iterate over a collection based
on a certain value of another collection
then you can use nested for Loops or you
have a scenario where you have to
iterate over or 2D or 3D arrays for
example if we were dealing with 3D
arrays then you would have seen three
nested for Loops here and where it will
apply the same logic that iterate over
all the collections all the values of
the inner loop on our particular value
of the outer loop then increment the
value of the outer loop and do the same
thing again I trade over all the values
of the inner loop based on a fixed value
of the outer loop so let's run this
program and let's see what kind of
output do we get so like I said our our
motive our Target was to print this in
in a metric style and you can see that
it is printing in it in a sort of a
matrix representation so the first row
gets printed here then the second row
gets printed here and then the third row
gets printed here if you try to decipher
it it will work exactly the same way as
I explained so I equal to 0 0 Less Than
3 condition becomes true comes here J
equal to 0 J Less Than 3 condition
becomes true consider prints the array
of 0 comma 0 which is 2 then prints the
array of 0 comma 1 which is 7 0 comma 2
which is 9 then J becomes 3 it breaks
out of the loop goes up here I becomes
from 0 to 1 1 is less than 3 Yes again
comes here re initializes a fresh for
loop with a new J setting to zero and it
will go it will print the array of 1 0 1
1 1 2 then similarly array of two zero
two one two two so that's basically what
we are doing we are iterating we are
picking the first row and iterating all
elements of it picking the second row
iterating all all elements over it and
so on so forth you can do this for any n
dimensional kind of array or a
collection so what are objects and
object is an instance of class let's
have a look at an example in this
example animal is a class and dog is its
object the object dog has States and
behaviors we can have dogs with
different breeds sizes and colors these
are considered as the states of object
dog on Behavior side dog has Behavior
like barking eating and wagging tail so
an object has its own States and
behaviors now let's look at an example
using Java code there are many platforms
to run Java program so for this video
I'll be using IntelliJ so let's create a
new project let's name it as project 1
and finish there we go we have a new
project with we have a class with Main
and we have a main function so the code
that we write should always be written
in the main function so let's create a
new class to understand how the object
is used let's name it as student we need
variables so that we can access the
variables of this class so I'm gonna use
student ID with the integer type student
name
and students age
there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s i created an object
s of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this I'll use ID
and give a value similarly I'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a name
now we'll print its value
now we are going to run this program
let's see what output we'll get
and there it is we have name that simple
learn we have age and we have ID now let
us see an example how we can use
multiple objects for a single class so
let's get started let's create a new
project and I'm going to name it as
Vehicles because I'm gonna use cars and
bikes in this program so I'm gonna use
Vehicles as a combined form and yes here
we have a class Main and a function mean
now I need two classes for this program
so I'm gonna create two classes first
I'm gonna name it as bikes and the
second class I'm gonna name it as cars
so let's create variables for these
classes so in cars first I need string
name and I need the cost of the car so
cost can be integer as well because I'm
gonna use dollar sign in that so I'm
gonna use string because of that so same
thing I'm gonna do with bikes
now that our classes are created let's
create objects for this class so the
process is same but we are going to use
different names for the object first the
car class and I'm gonna name as car one
and yes we have created the first object
not to create the second object
similarly I'm gonna create five objects
of the Class Cars
and I'm gonna change the name for them
so I created five objects of the same
class so I'm gonna create five objects
of the bikes class as well so bike one
will be a bit longer so I'm gonna use B1
till B5
and I'm gonna name them to from B1 to B5
so now I'm gonna assign values to the
variables that I created in classes bike
and cars so first I'm gonna go with cars
and let's name it as Lamborghini
similarly Car 2 Ferrari
so I am gonna use names of the cars that
are very famous and costly so that
anyone over the world can understand
this so let's name car 3
I'm gonna name it as Bugatti
similarly car 4
Pagani and car 5.
now I'm gonna give names for bikes
I hope everyone will understand the
names that I give
B4
and B5 last one Yamaha
now let's assign the cost for bikes and
cars as well so the procedure is same so
let's do it 130 000.
same B2 so B1 goes for Harley Davidson
B2 for Ducati B3 for Suzuki B4 for E cos
and B5 for Yamaha I am going to assign
values for these values accordingly for
Ducati to thirty two thousand
dollars
for Suzuki 200 000
300 000.
and the last one Yamaha 500 000.
now similarly I'm gonna assign values
for carbon.cost till card 5 dot cost
two hundred three thousand dollars for
Lambo I think I can copy paste these as
well so let's copy paste it a lot faster
and easier to do
Car 2 car 3 car 4 and car five
we don't need this as per car 2 let's
take it as 252
000 and let's make it it's 3 million
uh as per this let's keep it as 1
million
400 000 and lastly uh let's take as 293.
now that we have assigned all the values
for all this now let's print it and get
the value I'm gonna create a very simple
program but a very user-friendly program
so it's gonna be interesting for you
guys so we are going to ask the users
what do they like either bikes or cars
so we need to give them the options and
our next program will be based on the
options that the users select not the
options we give as the command so let's
do it
let's give the options
one
bikes
and two cars I need to take the value
that user gives for this I'm gonna write
this command
so I have not used scanner yet so let's
import scanner
and let's create a object for scanner
and yes let's get back so the data type
of choice variable is integer that's why
I'm using next int if the data type was
string then I would have used next line
so now that we have Choice from the user
let's use this value
if the user chooses the first value that
means bikes so the next thing we display
is we have models and we are going to
give five models for bikes to the user
here I am giving options to the user so
that they can choose easily from number
one to five
now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that I'm gonna ask which one
would you like to choose
to enter the choice I'm gonna use one
more variable let's say n so I'm gonna
store n
f n is equal to equal to 1 that means
Harley Davidson then I'm gonna show the
cost of Harley Davidson
this is the syntax to print the value
for the cost or any of the variable that
we use in class
what if the user says second or third or
fourth or fifth so for that we are going
to use else if statements
if n is 2 that means Ducati so we have
to show the rate of Ducati or the cost
of Ducati to the user
now similarly I'm gonna do for n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 4 and N is
equal to 5.
now I'm gonna do for n is equal to 4
and lastly n is equal to 5 that is our
last bike Yamaha
what if the users put a number that is
not between one to five so for that I am
going to use else statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
1 and 5.
so now we have code for bikes and the
same thing what if the user selects that
he wants to find the car so for that we
have this the choice is equal to is
equal to 1 so the same thing we are
going to do for choice is equal to is
equal to 2
and the same thing we are going to tell
to user that we have five models
same names that I gave to variables I'm
gonna give this to here
second one Ferrari
third book RT
fourth ecos
and the last one
posh
now we are going to ask the users the
choice that which number do they want to
choose
now we need one more value so that we
can have it as a variable which can
store the choice of the user so for this
I am going to use C
now if C is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of Lamborghini that he puts the choice
as one so we're going to display this
message the cost of Lamborghini
and we are going to use else if Loop to
enter the next values for C from 1 to 5
if C is equal to is equal to 2 that
means the user wants to know the rate of
Ferrari then we are going to show the
cost of the Ferrari
same thing if the user enters 3 as the
choice
if user enters 4 as their choice then we
go for a Cause
and the last one if user enters the
Choice as 5
then we have to display the cost of posh
now what if the user enters none of the
values from one to five then we have to
display a message
showing that
please enter the value
between 1 to 5. now remember the first
choice that we wanted from user to enter
either bikes or cars so what if the user
do not enter either one or two so for
that we need one more else function to
tell the user that either enter 1 or 2.
and with this we have completed our code
so now let's run this program for this
we need to go to run and then run main
there's a shortcut for it that is shift
plus F10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program Let's test this program now
so enter your choice I'm going to enter
one and yeah we have five models Harley
Davidson Ducati Suzuki Pagani and Yamaha
so enter your choice I'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have a result the cost of
Harley Davidson is 130 000 so with this
we have completed our code and please
feel free to type this code in your own
computer and try out all the permutation
and combinations that you can with this
program so with this let's move on to
classes and understand the classes and
their concept then we'll have a new
program on classes now let's see what is
a Class A Class is a blueprint from
which objects are created a class
describes state or behavior of an object
in this example dog is a class the
variables in this class are breed and
color the functions or methods of the
class dog are barking hungry and
sleeping we use objects of a class to
use variables and functions of the class
with this let's understand classes with
a simple Java code let's create a new
project
next tick the box and let's name it as
automobiles
let the base package be student and yes
we have a class main now let's create
some classes to do code on
I'll create a new Java class as cars
and then I'll create one more class with
the name bikes
and then one more class automobiles
so I'm gonna connect cars and bikes with
automobiles so that we can use that
program in Main and see what can we do
with the classes that we create in
automobiles I need some variables
I'll take private double and let's say
Fuel and then same thing private double
and then year and let's take one more
private string and brand now let's have
get us and set us for this so these are
used to get the value and set the value
for the variables inside the class
there we go we have the Getters and
Setters for it now let's go to class
cars so public Class Cars extends
automobiles
so in it I'm gonna create one more class
or a Constructor
and I'm gonna print a message say a new
car has been created car has been
created now the same thing I'm gonna do
with Bikes let's go to bikes and I'm
gonna use the same thing extends
automobiles this is because I can
inherit all the variables from the
automobiles class so I created a
Constructor and I'm gonna print a
message a new bike has been created
so I have created Class Cars bikes and
Automobiles so let's go to main program
so this is where we should write our
code so I'm gonna start with the code
now it's a very simple code I'm gonna
first I'm gonna create the variables or
the objects of the class with private
bikes bike so one is car and one is bike
both are objects for the classes so I'm
gonna use this objects
bikes bike is equal to new bike
this is so that my object can function
really well and now I'm gonna run it it
will take some time to run
and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that I typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes so I am
going to bikes so I'm going to create a
new method or a new function public void
kick for bike so I'm gonna print message
the bike has been started with kick bike
has been started with kick now the same
thing I'm gonna do with cars now how
does a car start with the key so I'm
gonna make a function public key and
inside it I'm gonna print the same
message car has been started with key I
should write void there to give the
return value as wide so let's print the
message car has been started with key
rotation let's write that as well so in
the main program I'm gonna use objects
to use those functions and let's see
what changes they will do to our program
Pike dot kick and car dot cake let's run
this
and there we go first we used to have
this two messages but now these two
messages are also there as well because
we invoked those functions and methods
that are there in class cars and bikes
so if I write bike dot key or car dot
kick this won't work this is because key
is not a method of bike or kick is not a
method of car so that's why I gave
private static for the functions so if I
execute it these are the error messages
that I'll get cannot find the symbol
method kick or method key let's talk
about arrays in Java and erase a data
type that contains homogeneous elements
homogeneous means all the elements in
the array are of the same data type and
array is a group of like typed variables
that are referred to by a common name on
screen you can see the Syntax for array
in Java now let's have a look at an
example or all the components of this
array are of the same data type integer
each of these elements has an index
value associated with it the index is
the position of the elements inside the
array the index of an array always
starts with 0. now let's talk about
features of an array in Java arrays are
dynamically allocated this means the
compiler does not need to know the exact
amount of memory required for the
program in advance next all elements are
stored under one name this means that
the elements of an array are known by
their array name lastly array occupies
contiguous memory location an array is
stored in adjacent memory locations
unlike linked lists now let's have a
look at an example using Java code on
how to declare and use arrays
let's create a new project
next
tick the Box
let's name it as array program
our class main is created and let's
write a code for arrays
first the syntax we use in Java the data
type int bracket and name of the array
let's take ARR now we have to give size
of the array
the name of the array is equal to new
end and the length you want for the
array let's take it as 5. so now let's
give values to the elements of the array
as the array starts with 0 I'm going to
assign 0 and then give a value 10.
similarly for the index 1 I am going to
give value as 20. for index 2
30. for index 3
and lastly for index 4 50.
now let's print the elements of the
arrays for this I am going to use for
Loop
for INT I is equal to 0 as the index
starts with 0 I less than array of
length and I plus plus
now let's print the statement using
system dot out
element
element at index let's print the index
first index is I
and next is is and the value of the
element ARR of I
now let's run this program
this might take a while
as you can see the program has executed
successfully
and the result the value of the index
and the value of the element is shown 0
to 10 till 4 to 50. now what if we put
an extra element let's try it out
we have five elements and the next
element I am going to put as 5 and give
it as 60 and I'm gonna run it shift F10
so this gives an error as you can see
the error was out of bounds exception
and it gives 5 because the length of the
array was 5. now that we have seen a
basic program of array let's move on to
the types of arrays and let's look at
examples using them
we have three types of arrays first we
have a one-dimensional array it is also
known as linear array and the elements
are stored in a single row as you can
see the example above the name of the
array is array with data type integer
five indicates that the array can store
five elements the index goes from 0 to
4. next we have a two dimensional array
two dimensional arrays towards the data
in rows and columns if you can see the
example the array has two rows and five
columns the index starts from 0 comma 0
in the left upper corner to 1 comma 4 in
the right lower corner and lastly
multi-dimensional arrays has combination
of two or more arrays or nested arrays
now let's have a look at an example of
one and two dimensional arrays using
Java code let's create a new project
next
tick the box next and let's name it as
dimensional arrays
now we have a class mean
the class mean
there are two ways we can assign array
one I have done before this is the
second time you can use to assign values
declare and Define array we use two
flower brackets and write the values
inside it separated by commas
and then semicolon this is how we
declare array in the starting
now we need a sum so that we can have
some of the arrays assign it as 0
and then we are going to use for Loop to
get the sum of all the arrays for INT I
is equal to 0
I less than array length
and I plus plus
now we are going to get sum of arrays
sum plus is equal to array of I now
let's print the sum of this array system
dot out Dot println
and write something sum of array is
and print array sum
and let's execute it
and yes we have our output
this is sum of array is 15. if you add 1
2 3 4 5 you will get the sum as 15 this
1 2 3 4 5. now let's delete everything
and try to do two dimensional arrays for
this we use int array name let's call it
as ARR and two brackets now we use a
flower bracket and one more flower
bracket for rows
in close I'll type it one two three in
second row 4 5 6 so with each bracket
rows are divided and the elements inside
the rows are known as columns now we use
for Loop we are going to use two for
Loops first one is int I
is equal to 0 I less than 2 because
there are only 2 rows and I plus plus I
need to change the bracket yeah and
declare one more for Loop and J is equal
to 0 J
is equal to 0 J Less Than 3 because
there are three columns and J plus plus
yeah and let's now print the values
system dot out
array of I and array of J and give it a
space now I need one more line to get to
the next line after printing one row so
for the next line I am going to use
system.out.println and I'm gonna delete
that and then before and now let's
execute it
here we have our Result One Two Three
are in a row 4 5 6 is the second row so
now let's try it with multi-dimensional
what if I put one more row inside it 7 8
and 9 so that means I have to change the
value for I I Less Than 3 because now we
have three rows and now let's execute it
and yes we have our result we have three
rows now one two three four five six and
seven eight nine I hope you like this
demo now let's move on to the next topic
sorting and searching for arrays now
let's talk about searching and sorting
using arrays first let's understand
sorting using an example we have an
array of seven elements from index 0 to
6. the value of elements are given in
random order then we use sorting
algorithm to sort the array in ascending
order when the algorithm is applied you
can see the result on the screen all the
elements in the array are sorted in
ascending order this is how sorting
works now let's move on to searching in
arrays in this example again we have an
array of Seven Elements suppose we have
to find The Element 11 in this array we
execute a swatching algorithm to find
the element you will see the result
something like 11 number founded index
5. so this is how searching Works in
normal array so now let's see examples
of sorting and searching using Java code
so there are many types of searches but
for this program we are going to use
binary search algorithm so let's create
a new project
new project
next
tick the box next and let's name it as
searching
we have our main program here now let's
create a new class
right click new Java class
and name it as binary search
we have a new class here so first I'm
going to create a Constructor sorry into
binary search now what is binary search
really binary search compares the target
value to the middle element of the array
if they are not equal the half in which
the target cannot lie is any if they are
not equal the half in which the target
cannot align is eliminated and the
search continues on the remaining half
again taking the middle element to
compare the target value and repeating
this until the target value is found so
for this I need
int array int left L into right value R
and the element I want to find is X
so sometimes there are only one element
in the array so to make sure there are
two or more than two elements in the
array we are going to use the right
element is greater than 1. if write R is
greater than equal to 1
then the code starts we need a mid value
to get the middle element int mid is
equal to we have to calculate it left
plus right minus 1 divided by 2 one more
bracket there
and what if the middle element is the
element we are trying to search for then
if ARR of mid is equal to X
then I'm gonna return mid
this means I am going to return the
value of the mid now what if the element
we are searching for is not the middle
element then if ARR ARR of mid
yes is greater than x then I am going to
return the same program the same
Constructor binary search
of ARR
left and now the right becomes mid minus
1. and the limit I want to find X
if ARR of mid is less than x for that I
am going to write this sentence return
binary search of array now in this case
left becomes mid plus 1 right remains
same R and the element X now I need to
return a value for this Constructor
because the data type of this instructor
is int I need to return some integer
value for this return -1 I think I need
to delete one bracket this bracket yeah
now this class looks fine let's move on
to main class in main class first I need
to take the scanner so I am going to
import Java dot util dot scanner so I'm
going to write the code starting with
I'm going to create a object for scanner
so that I can scan all the elements that
the user inputs
scanner s is equal to new scanner system
dot in
and next I'm going to create object for
the class binary search
so binary search OB is equal to new
binary search
and yes I am going to declare one array
now and ARR is equal to new and let's
take the length of array as 5. now I am
going to print a message for the users
so that they can put the input system
dot out
and the message let's type enter the
elements of the array in ascending order
ascending order is essential for this
algorithm so that we can search easily
and this search is properly based on
this now to get the elements I'm going
to use for Loop for INT I is equal to 0
I less than array dot length and I plus
plus
now to take the element error of I is
equal to s dot next int now that we have
taken the value from the user now let's
ask the user which element they want to
find for this I am going to print the
sentence system dot out
enter the elements
you want to search for
now I am going to declare one more
variable num is equal to next next int
one more variable to get the length of
the array and N is equal to ARR dot
length now one more variable so that we
can store the result of the class
end result is equal to OB object of the
class binary search
dot binary search and the elements as
ARR left would be 0 right will be n
minus 1 length of the array minus 1 and
the element we want to find num now if
the result of the array is equal to
minus 1
the result that we passed in our class
binary search is equal to -1 then I am
going to print element
not present
and if the result is not -1 then I'm
gonna print the value of the element s
out
element
plus the number of the element name n u
m num plus and the index of it
and the index will be stored in the
result
now let's run this program and we have
successfully executed it there are no
errors in the program I'm gonna put the
elements now I've put five elements one
to five and to search for three and yes
I can see the result element 3 found at
index 2 and that's true index starts
from 0 so the element would be found at
index 2. so this was it for the binary
search algorithm you can try this method
or you can try with different elements
anything you want to do with this
program and now let's move on to the
next program for our searching
algorithms there are many sorting
algorithms but for this program we are
going to use bubble sort so let's get
started let's create a new project
tick the Box
next let's name it as bubble sort
we have our class Main
now let's create one more class
and I'll name it as bubble sort
a bubble sort is an internal extreme
sort instead of searching an array as a
whole the bubble sort works by comparing
adjacent pairs of objects in the array
if the objects are not in the correct
order they are swept so that the largest
of the two moves up so this is how
bubble sort Works let's try to do coding
on this
I'll create a new class
or mainly a Constructor with void bubble
sort
and parameters I am going to give as int
array
now I am going to use NS getting length
of the array
for this I'm going to require two Loops
two for Loops nested Loops one for I and
one for J so for this for I I'm gonna go
int I is equal to 0 I less than n minus
1 and I plus plus I am going to use one
more Loop J
J is equal to 0 J less than n minus I
minus 1
and J plus plus I have to assign int
data type and yes
and next I am going to use if Loop
if array of J ARR of J is greater than
ARR of J plus 1 that means we are
comparing two adjacent sides then I'm
gonna assign one temporary variable and
the temporary variable will contain ARR
of J
next I'm gonna swap J to J Plus 1.
array of J is equal to area of J plus 1
and lastly array of J plus 1 will
contain the value that is there in temp
error of J plus 1 is equal to Temp so
this will be the code for our bubble
sort algorithm and next I am going to
create one more
next I'm going to create one more
function to print the array
I am creating this function to print the
sorted array
the same thing I'm gonna assign end to
array of length
and then I'm going to type the message
sorted array
and next one more for Loop to print all
the elements of the array for INT I is
equal to 0 I less than
n i plus plus
now system dot out for printing the
array ARR of I and one space and next
system dot out Dot println
for the new line so this created our
bubble sort class now let's move on to
main class first I am gonna import the
scanner to get the value from the user
so import Java dot util Java
Dot util.scanner
and now we move on to the new code first
the object of the scanner
new scanner
system dot in and now I'm gonna create
an object for bubble sort
OB is equal to new bubble sort
so OB is the new object created for
bubble sort class
now I'm gonna assign array
and new integer for now let's take it as
and now message to enter the elements
enter the elements now I'm gonna use one
more for Loop
this is to get the values of the array
the same loop I less than array dot
length I plus plus
ARR of I is equal to s dot
next end now I'm gonna run the program
the class that we used in bubble sort OB
dot bubble sort of ARR
and now to print the message
this message is to print that all the
elements are sorted in the array this is
mostly used to make it as user friendly
so I'm for printing array one more
function
and now let's run the program and yes we
have executed successfully this program
I am gonna enter the elements 15924
and yes we have the sorted array all the
elements before were in not in order and
now all the elements are in ascending
order
similarly we can do with descending
order also if we put I as the maximum
and then reduce I and J by using I minus
minus or J minus minus so are you ready
to take your career to new heights the
demand for full stack web developers is
soaring in today's fast-paced world and
now simply learn presents the perfect
opportunity for you to excel in this
exciting field without post graduate
program in full stack web development
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the foundation to build full
stack web applications using the power
of Java programming language from the
basics of JavaScript to advanced level
Concepts like angular spring boot
hibernate jsps and MVC we have got you
covered what else can you expect from
this program this program includes
Caltech ctme postgraduate certificate
enrollment in simply learns job assist
receive up to 25 CEUs from Caltech ctme
simply learns job assist help you get
noticed by the top hiring companies
you'll also get to attend master classes
from Caltech ctme instructors live
virtual classes led by industry experts
Hands-On projects and integrated Labs
online convocation by ctme program
director 20 lesson and and five phase
and project let's see what strings are
and how we can use strings in Java Java
strings are objects that contains groups
of characters like arrays strings are
immutable as well immutable means one
string is created they cannot be changed
or manipulated if we use a string hello
they are stored in a memory location
like this 0 1 2 3 4 are the addresses of
the locations where each character of
the string is stored now let's move on
to creating strings there are two
methods of creating string string little
method and using new operator this is
the syntax of string on the screen first
string type then variable name is equal
to sequence of characters in double
quotes this is called as string little
method for new operator method we use
new operator and value of string is
given in the brackets now let's see a
simple program to understand the use of
strings with Java code let's create a
new project file new project next tick
the box next I'm gonna name it as
strings and for the base package I'm
going to name it as string as well
because all the programs I'm going to do
in this package for Strings
we have our main program right here the
main class now before importing the
strings we need to import some
preprocessive directives so for this for
this I am going to import Java dot IO
input output dot star star star means
everything inside the directive and I'm
gonna import
java.lang dot star this means I can do
all the operations that is needed for
Strings so there are two ways to declare
string this is the first one string s is
equal to Simply learn now we have a
string s and it contains the value
simply learn now I'm gonna print this
system dot out Dot println plus s or I'm
gonna name it as string I'll print
string first is equal to and then I'm
gonna print this so double quotes
string is equal to and plus s so let's
run this program
and there we go we have string is equal
to Simply learn so it took the value of
s and printed that
so let's see the next type of string how
we can declare the string
Str is equal to new string simply learn
so this is the second method how we can
declare string or assign the values to
string so to print it
I'm going to use string 2 is equal to
and then plus Str so let's execute this
as well
and as you can see we have string 2 is
equal to Simply learn as well so this
means both the methods are to declare
strings or to assign values to the
strings so you can use any of them I
prefer using first so it's easy that's
why you don't need to write new and
string so let's move on to the new topic
classes and strings we all know that
strings are immutable now what if we
want to change something inside the
string then we use these methods to
manipulate strings in Java first one is
string Builder the string builder in
Java represents a mutable sequence of
characters it is an alternative to
string class as it creates a mutable
sequence of characters next is string
buffer string represents fixed length
immutable characters of sequences while
string buffer represents growable and
writable character sequences it will
automatically grow to make room for
additions like appending inserting and
deleting next we have string tokenizer
as string tokenizer object internally
maintains a current position within the
string to be tokenized some operations
Advance this current position past the
characters processed string tokenizer
class in Java is used to break a string
into tokens a token is returned by
taking a substring of the string that
was used to create the string tokenizer
object now let's see different methods
for functions that can be done on
strings in Java we have lot of methods
or functions in strings these are few of
the methods that are used by programmers
frequently and we will be using in this
series of our Java tutorial first one we
have int length that returns length of
the string second we have string
substring int begin index that Returns
the substring for given begin index next
we have Boolean is empty that checks if
the string is empty or not next we have
string concat string Str that
concatenates the specified string next
we have string split string rejects
returns a split string matching rejects
next we have end index of end CH that
next we have string to lower case and
string to uppercase these are mostly
used when we want to convert a string
into a uppercase or into a lowercase
next we have string trim that removes
beginning and ending spaces of the
string if we have any beginning or end
spaces that may not be required for a
string then we use this next we have
static string value of int value this
method converts given type of into
string it is an overloaded method and
lastly we have string replace character
old and character new it replaces all
the occurrences of the specified
character value next let's have a look
at a program where we are going to
reverse a string and compare to string
this is going to be an interesting
program and you will be able to
understand a lot better so let's get
started so first we'll see how to
compare two strings and then we'll see
how to reverse a string so let's create
a new project file new project let's
click on next tick the box next I am
going to rename it as compare and
reverse because I'm going to do both the
programs in the same program and we have
our main function here to use some
classes or to use some methods we need
to import some of the strings from java
so I'm going to import strings dot
compare compare dot string compare
so let's write our code here so I'm
gonna use four strings first string S1
is equal to then I'm going to use new
string and I'm inside it I'm going to
name the string as simply learn
S capital and for the next string string
S2 is equal to new string
uh let's give it as practice for the
third string S3 new string let's give it
a study and for the first fourth string
we are going to match in the third
string to show all the outputs that's
possible study now we are going to
display some output using the function
equals so what equals does is it it
compare two strings so first I'm gonna
use it make it as user friendly by
writing comparing string 1 and then
comparing string 2 and then semicolon so
that everything will be separated you
can easily find out what the result will
be and then this is the main part S1 dot
equals and in the bracket S2 because we
are comparing S1 and S2 so S1 dot equals
S2 so this function automatically checks
whether S1 is equal to S2
now same thing we are going to do with
string S3 and string S4 again this user
friendly S3 and S4
semicolon S3 dot equals S4 we know that
S1 is not equal to S2 but S3 is
definitely equal to S4 so let's try it
with one more sentence so that we can
compare one more string so I'm gonna
compare S1 and S4 so I'll copy paste it
and instead of S3 I'll write S1 and same
I'll do with S1 dot equals S4 so let's
run this program oh before running we
have a error here so I'm gonna delete
that import because we have not used it
so now let's run the program and yes we
have a result comparing simply learn and
practice is false this definitely false
study and study both strings are
matching so it's true and simply learn
and study they don't match that's why
it's false so let's get started with our
second program that's reversing a string
so I'm gonna delete everything from here
and I'm going to write same code here
only so first I need to assign a
variable of string
string input equals and limit as simply
learn and this is the main part guys we
use string Builder because the string is
immutable and as I discussed earlier
string Builder allows us to do
manipulation so I'll use one more
variable input 1 and new string Builder
so in input 1 we can do any manipulation
that we require so first I'm gonna do
input1 dot dot append so that I can do
operations that I want on it either
reversing or deleting or concat so I'll
take append of input and lastly input 1
is equal to input 1 dot reverse this
function reverse the string that is
there in input 1.
now to print the value of the reverse
string
the reverse string is and then input 1.
so here's the catch guys we have to use
string Builder so that we can do
manipulations inside the string if we
don't use string builder then we will
get an error that unable to manipulate
the string or unable to reverse the
string so string Builder is the main
thing here so that we can do all the
operations that you want either
reversing or concat or deleting anything
from the string or deleting an element
or adding anything to the string so all
that happens because of string Builder
so now let's run this program
and there we go we have a result the
reverse string is the reverse of Simply
learn now let's try it with something
that is palindrome so we have our
language Malayalam if we reverse this
we'll get Malayalam so this is kind of
palindrome string and see the result the
reversing is also Malayalam so this is
how you reverse a string so this brings
us to the end of this video we learned
about strings the functions for Strings
and the methods we use in strings and
lastly we learn how to compare two
strings and how to reverse two strings
what is an abstract class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object oriented
programming approach and designing a
software
here the programmer tries to hide the
complicated implementation of the code
which makes the software run smoothly
most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it
to do so we use an abstract loss or
sometimes an interface based on the
requirement
so abstract class in Java is considered
as a template of methods and variables
which are used in a program remember
abstract classes cannot be instantiated
directly now moving ahead we will next
learn the important features of abstract
classes
so the first one is template the main
reason programmers prefer to use
abstract methods is because they act as
a predefined template for any future
specific class that you might use
next loose coupling is a procedure where
an internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible
after that we have the code reusability
implementation of the abstract classes
provides the developers with one of the
greatest features that saves time which
is none other than the code reusability
followed by code reusability we have
abstraction as discussed earlier data
abstraction is the process of hiding
certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or interfaces
last but not least
Dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
Dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process
the dynamic method resolution is a
mechanism by which a call to an
overwritten method is resolved at
runtime this is how Java implements
runtime polymorphism when an overwritten
method is called by reference Java
determines which version of that method
to execute based on the type of object
it refers to
now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes
alright let us go through the rules one
by one as mentioned below
the first one is the keyword abstract is
mandatory to declare an abstract class
followed by that the next rule says that
abstract classes cannot be instantiated
directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least one abstract method next
to that we have another rule which says
an abstract class includes final methods
next an abstract class may also include
known abstract methods it's not
mandatory that an abstract class should
only include abstract methods so the
last rule says that an abstract class
can include Constructors and static
methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in Java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in Java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in Java
so basically there are two different
ways to achieve abstraction in Java the
first way is by using abstract classes
and the next one is by using an
interface
now this brings us to our next topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract followed by that
we use the keyword called class then
after that we declare the name of our
class the name of the class is up to the
user's choice for example I have named
my class as simply learn as shown here
followed by the abstract class we have
the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now I have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
Choice as you can see I have used simply
learn as the name of the method
so this was by using abstract class
method the next one is by using an
interface method
now what exactly is an interface
so interface can be defined as a
boundary between the method and the
class implementing it in Java we use
interface to achieve abstraction
in other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program
now we will move ahead and understand
the syntax to use an interface to
achieve abstraction in Java
to declare an interface we use the
keyword call interface followed by that
we declare the name of a class
the class name is up to the user's
choice for example I have named my class
as simply learn as shown below
as discussed earlier interface acts just
as a container that stores only the
signatures of the method we cannot have
a complete method defined inside it all
we can do is just declare an interface
now that we have a detailed explanation
about the abstract class and the
interface
let us look into some example programs
based on abstract classes
now we have successfully booted the
Eclipse IDE now let's create a new
project
so to create a new project just click on
create a project
and this should give you a dialog box
wherein you have to select Java project
click next
now let us give a name to our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this process
as you can see the project has been
successfully created and inside the
project simply learn we have the source
file and right clicking the source file
will give us a Dropbox where you can
just select new and inside new you can
select a new package
now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the package
moving further let's right click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class
so the name of my class will be employee
let's click on finish to create the
class
now we have our employee class ready
now let's right click on the package and
select new and inside that
let us select another class
and the name of this particular class
will be person which will act as our
abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person
so our first example which is based on
employees where we will have an abstract
class called person and this person
class will be inherited by the employee
class and gets executed to generate
employee details
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
to execute the program just right click
on the package and go to the Run option
and select the first one that is Java
application
now you can see we have the employee
name pavitra and the gender as female
and the employee has logged in
successfully so these are the details
which we were expecting to be presented
on the output console now moving ahead
we shall execute our next example which
will be based on students
so here
the class student is the abstract class
and three different student classes
namely Raju pranitha and Punit will
inherit the student class and generate
the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that a
student has been declared using the
keyword abstract and inside that we have
an abstract method which is get rank
and these classes that are Raju pranita
and ponit will inherit the abstract
class student and display their ranks
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console
now let us move ahead and try to execute
one last example
based on abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks
here we have an abstract loss named loan
and all the banks described in the
program will inherit the loan abstract
class to calculate the rate of interest
on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is long and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we have the classes Andhra
Bank bank of Baroda idbc Bank State Bank
of India which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of Interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
is been displayed in the output console
so with this we have entered into our
next topic where we understand the
differences between an abstract class
and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword while we declare an
interface we use the keyword called
interface on the other hand when we
declare an abstract class we use the
keyword abstract
followed by that the second difference
is when you use an interface the
subclasses basically Implement an
interface
while on the other hand when you use
abstract classes the subclasses extend
an abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract class
followed by that the third difference is
multiple interfaces can be implemented
but on the other hand only one abstract
class can be extended at one particular
instance
and the final difference between the
both s interface is capable to support
multiple inheritance whereas on the
other hand abstract classes are not
capable to support multiple inheritances
multiple inheritance is none other than
the diamond problem which is not
supported in Java
now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract loss
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in Java are
the abstract classes are highly
beneficial in writing shorter codes the
abstract classes avoid code duplication
they enable code reusability which is a
major advantage and finally the last
Advantage is changes to the internal
code implementation can be done without
affecting the classes
so these were few of the major
advantages of using an abstract class
now moving ahead we shall discuss the
disadvantages of using abstract classes
few of the disadvantages of using an
abstract class in Java are abstraction
is expensive as sometimes you need to
handle cases and situations which are
not necessary
followed by that the second disadvantage
is object relational impedance must
match in the case of rdbms and the last
disadvantage is object relational
mapping in case of Frameworks like
hibernate so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in Java that you need to consider before
using them into your project
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this Shield as you can
see variables and methods are defined
inside one class like a capsule now the
question is why do we need encapsulation
the main reasons are first better
control of class attributes and methods
second class attributes can be made read
only or write only third it makes Java
code very flexible this means the
programmer can change one part of the
code without affecting other parts apart
from these encapsulation is mainly used
to protect data and increase security of
the code as you can see to protect the
data variables must be private and they
can only be accessed through methods now
let's see Java code for encapsulation to
understand the cons except better so now
let's create a new project
next
and I'm gonna name it as
and cap one
so here we have our main class we can
write the code here so before writing
the code let me create a new class
right click new Java class
and I'm gonna name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employee using
employee Name ID and salary so in this
class let me create variables
first string name
then
integer ID
and then in salary
so I can easily use these variables in
our main program by creating object of
the class so let me just create the
object
employee e is equal to new employee
now I can use e dot ID name or salary
anything I need to but this program is
about encapsulation so this is an easy
program we can do but in order to secure
our programs when we have a large number
of program and large number of lines in
a program so we need encapsulation at
that time so that data can be secured so
for that I'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so I
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if I write ID
we'll get a red color here so if we go
on it we can see ID has private access
so that means we can't use it directly
because of this we need Getters and
Setters that are normally methods that
are used for these so right click
generate and here you can see Getters
and Setters so just select all of them
and ok so now we can use these methods
instead of direct using the variables so
we can get in the starting then set then
get and again set so likewise it goes
like this so now we have set here so if
I want to declare variable and if I want
to put some value inside my variable so
how can I do that
here you can see get ID or get salary so
if I go for get ID sorry if I go for E
dot set ID and I set it as six so this
shows no error this means we can use
methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first I'm gonna
set everything
and lastly e dot set salary let's get it
as thirty thousand maybe in dollars or
maybe in rupees let's just set it as 30
000 for now
so how I'm gonna print it for this I'm
gonna go to a print statement and then
name
and E dot not set name but this time I'm
gonna go with get name get name is to
return the value of the name that I have
given so in this case that's simply
learn
and next will be ID
and E dot get ID
and lastly salary
e dot get salary
so this is a simple program that is used
to Define encapsulation we don't use
private variables that becomes a normal
program so when we use encapsulation we
are going to use private every time
whenever we declare variables so that
it's secure and no one can access the
variables directly
so now let's run the program
and there we go we have our result we
have executed the program successfully
and as you can see name simply learn ID
6 and salary is 30 000. so I hope you
understood the concept of encapsulation
so the main concept of encapsulation is
all the variables can be accessed
through methods so for this we use
Getters and Setters that are inbuilt
functions for IntelliJ or netbeans or
Eclipse so with this let's move on to
our next program to understand it better
and how we can manipulate these
variables or methods using program so
again let's create a new project
and this time I'm gonna name it as
encapsulation 2 because it's the second
program for encapsulation
and here we have our main program now
this time I'm gonna use an example of
cars so let me just create a new class
and I'm going to name it as cars
so in this again I'm gonna create three
variables that are private
so first I'm gonna get string name
then private string price that means
price of the car
and third one
top speed of the car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but I'm gonna explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so I'm gonna
create a Constructor for the class cars
and inside I am gonna give it as
arguments as string name
then string price
and string top speed
and I'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name
this is so that the class can identify
that we are going to give arguments
related to that and the class can return
the values of it
so similarly I'm gonna give it as this
dot price
is equal to price
and lastly
this top speed is equal to top speed
so with this we have completed our
Constructor for it now let's have
Getters and Setters for the same thing
for these three variables
so generate getter and setter
select all and ok
this is a great feature that we have in
Java Getters and Setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program
we'll write the code here first I'll
create object of the Class Cars
and inside this I'm gonna give arguments
or inside this I'm gonna give values
that I use in Constructor to assign the
values without using any c dot get name
or C dot get price
so my first was name so let me just name
it as BMW
the second thing was price so I'm gonna
give it as thirty thousand dollars
and the third one was top speed so top
speed I'm gonna give it as 200 kilometer
per hour so we have assigned all the
values to the variables and we have
created object as well all in the same
line so this is another way of creating
objects or another way of assigning
values to the variables that are private
so if I try to print these they can be
easily printed
so in the starting name
and C dot so this time I'm gonna give
get name so it automatically gets the
value that I assigned to the variables
through Getters and setters
after that price
C dot price get price
and in the end
top speed
C dot get top speed so if I print this
let's execute it
and there we go we have name BMW price
and even the top speed now if I give
spaces between them
it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more
and here you go name BMW price thirty
thousand dollars and top speed 200
kilometer per hour so this is one of our
ways how we can declare variables or
assign values to the variables without
using any Getters or Setters so in this
method we used only Getters to print the
value that we have for variables now how
can we manipulate the variables if we
want to change value of them now for
this again I can do set top speed or set
price let the name be as it is
so C dot set price
so price I'm gonna set it as
fifty thousand dollars
and C dot set top speed let me increase
it to 250 kilometer per hour
so before printing that I'm so that we
can differentiate which one is new and
which one is old I'm gonna print one
more line
stats after
updation
so now if I print these values I'm just
gonna copy paste it
so now if I print it let's execute it
and here you go first we have name price
and top speed then stats after updations
that means after we set the value the
value gets overwritten on the variables
and now we have a new price and top
speed and all the details so this is how
you can manipulate variables or values
inside the variables what is inheritance
there are two other key terms which are
not going to be in this agenda but you
should also when you get to them make
sure you bundle them together as you're
understanding these structures and
that's the abstract class and the
polymorphism so what is inheritance
inheritance is an act through which a
new class gets created by acquiring the
variables and methods defined in the
previous parent class
so we look at what is inheritance we can
take an example of say food we have
veggies noodles fruits where food is the
parent and your veggies your noodles and
fruits are all subclasses of that
they're all kind of children of food
why do we need inheritance
we Implement inheritance for multiple of
reasons like creating a possibility to
add or remove features
to reduce the code length as we reuse
the code more comfortable to develop and
maintain the project
and so if we start looking at let's say
we have a cell phone we make calls we
have our SMS texting our communication
on our phone we have our media we also
add a browser on there because now we
have a smartphone
when we look at that we have our phone
set up and then we have our full
smartphone media call SMS and browser
and we start to kind of Link these
instead of making them separate we can
have the call and the text and then we
can have them inherit we can actually
create a media that inherits their
quality so now you can text your media
now you can use the browser as part of
your call scenario
and I would even add one more example in
here and that is that all programming
languages that are object based are
built on inheritance Java python C plus
plus so this concept of building an
object and then that object then is
inherited by everything underneath of it
is important to understand even in these
most even as we're looking at more
specific cases
so we'll take a look at the components
of inheritance
and the most important two components in
inheritance the two major components
that are mentioned are parent class or
the super class and the child class or
the subclass
and to see this let's go ahead and jump
into eclipse and take a look at what the
actual code looks like
so the first thing I want to do is go
ahead and add in a new
package
and we're going to go ahead and call
this package
inheritance because that's what we're
working with
oops
give me a default Java tutorial in there
inheritance finish and I started off
with the Java tutorials just a um
went in and created a new project and
made sure it was Java based so we have
our package inheritance right here we're
going to go ahead and add in a new class
and we'll go ahead and call this class
machine now one of the standards when
you're creating classes to capitalize
the first letter so always remember to
do that in some places people like to
have the whole word capitalized it
really depends on who you're working
with but it is kind of if it starts with
a capital letter it's probably a class
and so once we have our inheritance we
have our public class machine
let's go ahead and give it a little bit
underneath there to do something and
we'll start with um
uh protected
string brand and so whatever machine
we're working with uh these particular
machines are going to be we'll call them
it'll be a Samsung
free
they get some free vocab free marketing
right there for Samsung
so Samsung machines
and then we wanted to do something so
let's go ahead and put a procedure in
there I'll make it public
voids it's not going to return anything
and we'll call this uh wash I guess
they're all wash machines
there we go there's our brackets a
little trouble finding the bracket on
there and let's just have it during this
we'll just have it do a Quick Print line
and we'll say um
initiating
cycle
there and then of course our semicolon
on the end
all right so now we have a public class
machine and we're going to get into
where we start working with the actual
inheritance you can create an object
with this machine we haven't done
anything special to it it's like any
other class you might create in the Java
language and we've added in public void
wash a procedure with no return that's
what the void means and it's going to
print out and so let's go ahead and
create another class in here new class
foreign
and this one's going to be washing
machine
washing
and uh
we'll go ahead and hit finish on here
and we come into our washing machine
it's opened up a nice new tab for us
we might have a private string model
name
I want to change this to model type
model type equals
so the type of machine is is a top load
washing machine
so we have a Samsung as a main type of
machines we're looking at we have top
loader or top loading washing machine
and then we're going to add up here
extends
machine
and so this is the the key code we're
going to look for because we want this
to have the properties of the machine
so this comes in and says whatever is in
machine we now also have in our washing
machine
and then of course if we're going to do
all this we need to actually be able to
run it and if we're going to do that we
want to go ahead and add in the public
static
void main reserved keywords there and
this is just your standard main startup
you have your string of arguments
and of course our bracket and then in
here
we're going to take and create a washing
machine object
and so here's our wash machine
it's of course the type washing machine
and it's going to equal a new
washing machine so we're initiating a
new object in here there we go
and then we want to do something
and if we're going to have it do
something we wanted to go ahead let's
see what happens we have wash remember
our keyword up there was washing machine
dot wash
and where did that come from well if we
go back into machine
here it is public void wash there's the
procedure and it's coming into the
washing machine and this is inherited
that way we don't have to retype that
every time we have a washing machine
this could be washing machine
maybe the next one is I don't know a
different kind of washing machines I'm
not an expert on washing machines
we have to do a wash
and then specific to the washing machine
in here
we also had uh the type and so we can
come back up here or brand
so we can come up down here we can go
system
dot print line
wash machine Dot
brand
Plus
I'll put a little Dash in there
um
Plus
and then we're going to go ahead and we
have our wash
machine Dot model type
that model type we put in there so the
brand where does the brand come from the
Brand's coming from our machine we have
our protected string which is going to
be Samsung
and then we have our washing machine
which has the model type which is a top
load machine and if we go ahead and run
this
after of course we make sure that
semicolon in on the end there
we come up there we'll see initiating
cycle initiating cycle is printed out
from machine and then the Samsung top
load washing machine is the second
printout line here
and so when we have our wash print out
here also the wash machine wash is
initiating cycle and then we have that's
where that printout comes from we can go
back up here to machine you can see
right here initiating cycle
and then we flip back over to the
washing machine we print out wash
machine dot brand which is the machine
class and then wash machine dot model
type which is underneath the washing
machine
so let's go over all that let's take a
look and see what we're talking about
here
so we saw in the code the extends
keyword the term extends is a pretty
defined keyword in Java that allows you
to create a new child class by deriving
the variables and methods from the
parent class to reduce code length and
improve the performance
and we see that right up here in our
public class washing machine extends
machine
so the next key thing to talk about is
access modifiers
and I kind of breezed over them when I
put together the code but we'll dig in
there a little deeper we talk about axis
modifiers there's four different words
you really need to know and that's
default
public protected and private
and I'm going to tell you right now
default equals public
so what is default default access
modifier is set implicitly whenever you
declare a class without a specific
access modifier by default the axis of a
class or method when declared without a
specific access modifier becomes
available to any other method or class
within the same package and in Java the
default is public so public a certain
class can be declared as public by using
the keyword public any class or method
when declared is public becomes
available to any class or method
declared in the same package but if a
different method or class needs it it
should be imported
and then we have protected certain
classes declared protected by using the
keyword protected this provides access
to the methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and then private a certain class is
declared protected by using the keyword
private this provides the ultimate
protection to the data members and the
methods of the private class this
procedure is implemented by class to
encapsulate the method and members
so uh we'll take a a little we're
actually going to do a different example
in here but I do like this underneath
the washing machine
you can see right here we have put in
private a private string
what this means is that only washing
machine can access that private string
where if you have protected the children
can access it so protect the screen if
you're underneath a machine up here we
have protected
so that when I create the washing
machine and extend machine I can still
access it but if I create a sub class of
washing machine in a market as private
that subclass is not going to be able to
access it and so it has to do with what
layers of accessing
think of this as a big team project you
create something do you really want that
to Cascade down to the next class or who
do you want to have access to that
let's go a little deeper to really bring
this home because it's really important
to understand these terminology let's go
ahead and start a new class here and
we're just going to call this particular
class summation
and go ahead and create that finish
and so our summation class it's going to
be pretty simple in here we'll go ahead
and do uh
public
so anything buddy can access it just
remember here's our public on there and
then we'll just do a integer because
that's what's going to return as an
integer we're going to call it add and
we're going to put integer X comma
integer y
and
and we'll just return X Plus y so real
simple we're just adding two numbers
here's our two inputs they both have to
be integers and we're going to return an
integer and it'll be the summation of
the two so real simple class right there
and if we're going to have a summation
and let's go ahead and create a new
class and we'll call this one child
and in our new child class
we're going to go ahead and keep this
simple and we're just going to have our
public static main we're going to have
our summation a equals new summation and
then system out print line a DOT add 100
plus 200.
pretty straightforward everything's
public in here oops okay there's our
running and we see the answer is 300.
so this is public if you remember
quickly we're talking about public
and so when we use the public keyword
any class or method when declared as
public becomes available to any class or
method declared in the same package
but if in a different method or class
needs it it should be imported
so here we go it's that's our public
setup it's just open to everybody well
everybody that's under the package
inheritance so whoever's using that
package can now use the this particular
child
and let's go ahead and add a new class
in and this time we're going to do a
parent class
I'll just put that right in there
and we come in with our parent class you
can see right here the parent class
itself is public what we want to do
underneath the parent class is we want
to create a protected
void because we're not returning
anything and print so we're going to do
the print there and this protected print
let's go and put our brackets in there
and we'll do just a simple uh print line
hello world
and once we have that print hello world
we want to go ahead and add a child
class to this
and let's see we already well we had the
child class when it took it out a second
ago so we'll go ahead and put that back
in uh here's our child class
and for this childhood class we wanted
to go ahead and extend the parent
so inheritance there's our extend on
there oops let me retype that
all right extends parent so now the
child class is part of the parent class
and we'll go ahead and put our main in
there so that it will run it and execute
it and we'll create our child X
equals new
child class
let me go ahead and assign our variable
X and initiate it and then we'll do just
the print and see what happens here so
here's our print statement
and we'll go ahead and run this and
compile our child on there
and when it comes in there you see it
says print hello world and so the parent
has marked this as protect it so it's
protected from objects that are not
inheriting it but the child can still
access that information and print it on
there
so here's protected this provides access
to methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and a lot of programming that's usually
where you end up is doing a lot of stuff
that is underneath your parent
that is protected either make them
public or protected a lot of people are
sloppy and just make them public but
most of the stuff you want to make sure
it's protected and then we finally have
our private and I'm going to go back
here to our child and we're going to run
this
and it's going to come up and say
proceed with launch errors in setup and
then it's going to give us an exception
thread Main
compilation error the method print from
the type parent is not visible and
that's because unless you actually
initiate the parent you're not going to
see this code because it's private it's
only private to the public to the parent
class so even if I extend it in child
it will not be available and that again
protects it that means it's something
that you don't want to inherit and
Cascade down because maybe it is a piece
of code that is going to be changed and
so you don't want all the children to
crash every time you make a change to it
so with private this provides the
ultimate protection to the data members
in the methods of the private class this
procedure is implemented by class to
encapsulate the methods and members so
very important we have private and we
have protected and we have public the
more access you want other pieces of the
software code to have and other
programmers to have the more public you
want to make it and of course the
default is public
now one of the common workarounds for
this because you're going to have
protected data but you still want it to
be used by the subclasses is to create
what they call like a get or a and we'll
do it up here we'll go ahead and do a
private
integer x equals five
and then instead of on your inheritance
instead of having it uh call it from
the child we might have a get thing or a
gith thing we might have a public
gonna return an integer
and we might have it say get X
and this simply just return X
and what this means is that we have
something simple like this where it just
doesn't return X I can go back into my
child here
and instead of print X we'll do x dot
get X
and we'll go ahead and print this out
or you know something simple with that
we'll go ahead and do a uh
system print line on this
and when we run this
you'll see it come up it's going to
recompile and we get our five What's
Happening Here is now I've created
underneath the parent
private information you don't know
what's going on with it it's protected
you might have a procedure that's
protected in this case we had the print
procedure and then we access it from the
public and this could have easily have
been instead of maybe we'll just call it
public
void
public print
kind of a goofy way of doing the code
there we go and then it could go in here
and access our print
and so we can actually still access this
print variable up here by wrapping it in
kind of a git or a public function this
allows us to protect whatever code is
going on in the parent class so it can't
be messed up it can't be accessed
indirectly it has to go through the
right processes and so when we get to
the child on here the child can then
still has the public processes but all
the other information isn't is protected
and is private it's really important to
remember that private right there
this brings us to Super keyword
and we talk about the super keyword a
super keyword eliminates the confusion
between parent class method and subclass
method super keyword is implemented to
access a method or Constructor that is
defined in the parent class
so back in Eclipse we'll go under parent
and we'll take this we're gonna take the
private out of there so now we have an
integer five
and we'll go ahead and just remove the
print because we're not going to do that
in the parent
whoops in the public
there we go and so let's create a parent
that just has one piece of information
it has an integer x equals five
and then we're going to go to the child
and let's go ahead and add in here
integer x equals 10. and these are by
default they're public we haven't set
anything on here telling it what it is
and so what I'd like to do is we'd like
to go ahead and create a
oops one more thing there we go create a
procedure here
and we'll just call this void Capital
print this is going to be a system out
print line and this is what I want you
to notice is we're going to print out X
and Super X so we have the child class X
and we have the parent class Super X and
if we come down here and we do X
Dot
print
don't forget my semicolon
add a couple spaces in here to make it
look nicer when we print it and we'll go
ahead and run this and you can see that
the child class prints 10 and the parent
class is five and so this way you can
actually store different information
depending on what it is you're working
on and what you're doing and that's
where this super comes in you can see
right here where the super
underneath the clasp and the print
module now you can't just put it in down
here under print
let me explore what that looks like if I
just take this and I go ahead and
highlight it
and let's say I wanted to just instead
of doing X print
it's going to come up right here right
off the bat you see the super dot X I
can do x dot super dot X and it's still
going to give me an error right here it
has to be underneath a procedure in the
actual class and not under the main
this brings us to types of inheritance
and there's four main types we have
single inheritance which we've already
pretty much looked at but we'll go back
over we have multi-level inheritance we
have hierarchical inheritance and Hybrid
inheritance let's go ahead and just
start with the single inheritance single
inheritance consists of one parent class
and one child class here child class
inherits parent class methods and data
members
and let's go ahead and create a new
class up here just to change it up and
keep it interesting new
class and we'll call this one student
uh and under the student
and we'll have a simple setup we'll just
do an enrolled and it'll say enrolled in
simply learned there we go so there's
our class student and then we'll create
another class uh we'll do it as a
because we have our student our base
student and then we'll call this one
new
class
hey we'll call this one uh computers
there we go so he's a rolled finish and
for computers let's go ahead and put in
a print line here
and we'll put down
studying
computers
and we want to go ahead and do the
extends extends
student so it's a student studying
computer subclass computers
and this would all look familiar because
we've been doing this for you know a lot
of the other setups this is your basic
inheritance
and we'll change that from enrolled to
studies
and then let's go ahead and put a main
in here so we can actually run it and we
have our P enrolled which comes from our
parent class and our P studies which
comes from the child or the um one
inheritance it the extends for student
and let's go ahead and run that there we
go run
and you can say enrolled in simply learn
studying computers
and then we can go on to the next setup
and this is where we look at multi-level
inheritance is also apparent child
inheritance relation but the difference
is the child class is inherited by
another child class
this is the basic structure of most
programming languages right here you
have an object you have all the
different things under the object and it
gets all the way down to whether it's an
array you're working with whether even a
class is a sub-child that goes all the
way up to the object and we can simply
do that in our code in the eclipse
and we'll just go ahead and add a new
class in there we'll call this one uh
Java there we go
oops Java and under Java we want to go
ahead and
oh create some of the similar stuff and
then I want to go back to my student I
took out the main and student just
because I don't want it to run the main
in there
and in here we're going to have system
out
um
we're gonna have instead of studying
computers Focus
on Java which is what we're doing right
now
and maybe we'll call this classroom and
then we can come down here and we have
our P equals new computers well instead
of new computers we want our Java and
it's going to be a Java object
and we need to put our extends in up
here
extends in this case we came from
computers
so there's our initial thing and then we
have our last print in here
and of course if we run this now we'll
see that it should if I did everything
correctly come up and say enrolled in
simply learn studying computers focus on
Java and we have the enrolled which is
the parent to computers and then we have
under computers well we have students
and computers and then Java and so each
one of these classes just Cascades all
the way down and this is your
multi-level from your class A to class b
to class C
and if you can have multi-level
inheritance we can also have a higher
archaeal inheritance where your
parent-child relationship the only
difference is here multiple child
classes inherit from one parent class
and that is pretty uh we'll do another
class here if you remember correctly we
had a student computers maybe from
student we'll have a set of computers
we'll have project management a project
management so you're studying your idol
and all your other classes in there for
Cascade and for doing agile programming
and in here we can do that it's just the
same as we did before we just have a
second child coming in from here and so
this would go ahead and extend extends
extends
student
and of course whatever subcategory you
have one in here for running this
and so for here we'd have like our void
studies in this case instead of studying
computers we're studying project
management project
management one of the other wonderful
classes it is taught from the simply
learned team
and we'll go and run that and you can
see right here we have computers oops of
course uh
instead of computers I meant to do
project
management there we go and we have to
also initiate it as a new
and then when we run here we can see
this we're enrolled in simply learn and
we're studying project management
and then finally there is the um the
hybrid the name itself explains it to us
the Hybrid inheritance can be a
combination of any of the three types of
inheritance supported in Java and so
maybe we already saw that because we
have our a and our B
if we flip back on over to our
Eclipse we have our student our student
now has a computers project management
so there's our um
hierarchical and then they're mixed
because we also have the Java which is
an extension of the computer and so we
have multiple layers there
so one of the issues that comes up with
inheritance in classes is what they call
the diamond problem
and in the diamond problem the Java
programming language does not support
multiple inheritance as it ends up with
serious ambiguity
and that is where we have D which
inherits from both B and C which might
both inherit from a
this is the diamond Factor because as
you start tracking your supers going up
which one are you actually looking at B
or C or a and that's why they call this
a diamond problem it comes up more than
you would think you get very complicated
structures and you realize oh I need to
have both sets of instructions come down
to whatever I'm working on and you can
see where that can become a problem
let us take a look at is a relation and
has a relation now these I mean they're
vocabulary but they're more of a concept
understanding how things fit together
and so we talk about is a relation when
a class inherits methods and members
from a different class than the
relationship is said to be is a relation
examples orange is a fruit
and oh let's just jump back on over here
and we'll make a
new
class and we'll call this class customer
so we're going to have our customers
oops
here we go if I can remember how to type
so we have a class customer and we have
gone ahead and our team in the back went
ahead and prepped this for us let's just
take a quick look though we got public
string name so it's accessed publicly if
you leave this out it'll automatically
be public because that's the default and
then we have our customer and the string
which is a name and a string is a city
and then when you do a customer and you
send it the name of the city it will do
this name equals name in this city
equals City we could have easily done
this private we have a call into it to
create it so it wouldn't really matter
too much whether we did it private or
public I would actually be more likely
to do it private
and for this example we'll go ahead and
create another class and we'll call this
Thor
we'll have our store class we have
customers and we have a store
and then we'll go ahead and
set up in here and this time we did do a
private we're going to create a list of
customer customers and then the store
list coming down and then this customer
customers and public list customers
a quick look at this is we did make this
one private which is nice because now it
can't be accessed externally except from
store and then the store has the public
list customers so we can send it a list
of customers and then it go ahead and
Returns the customers from that list and
then we add it to the store
it sets the customers in the store this
doc customers equals customers
one of the reasons we have the airlines
in here is I haven't compiled it so it
doesn't see the customers are part of
our package
and we'll get to that in just a moment
here
and then let's go ahead and create
another class we'll call this is a
relation
since that's what we're working on
and here's our is a relation setup
and we're just going to put this as the
main so you have your main in there and
then we went ahead and prepared a series
of customers
and we'll just call that customer C1
equals a new customer customer C2 equals
a new customer and we're just creating a
list here that's all we're doing
and if we're going to have a list and we
need to go ahead and create a list of
customers
and we'll just do that with a simple
list setup
and then we gotta add those customers
into the list so let's go ahead and do
that
so breaking this down we have a customer
one which is Raju Bangalore Shiva
hyperbad Sachin Mumbai and so on and
then we just created a list of customers
a new array of lists and then we add in
each of those customers so now we have a
nice list of all our different customers
in here and then we want to go ahead and
create our store
and we'll put in store and it'll be a
fruit smoothies franchise I put down
fruit smoothies French
maybe that's not a good abbreviation
because I think it's a French instead of
franchise there'll be a new store and
then we have our new store which is
um in this case we're going to put in
that new store customers and if you
remember we went back here into store
let me just flip back on over there
it's going to take that list of
customers
and put that into this customer so now
the private list is going to equal that
list of customers
and then of course we can come in here
and we do public list it's going to
return that list of customers so we have
public assets here and this door you can
add public at the beginning
we'll go ahead and do that just to make
it clear is it public is what's going to
run on there and let's go back into our
is a relation
and I hope so back to store I'm going to
go ahead and just change this to
customer list so here's our list
customer list and it's going to return
the customers from this selection from
our private variable
uh so we come into here
we can come down here and we'll go ahead
and put that in there we'll do a loop on
this we'll have a list customer and
we're going to create a list of our
customers from our fruit smoothies
franchise
and we'll get the customer list from
there and then for a customer in the um
in our four customer CST in customer
we're going to go ahead and just print
that name out there
now at this point if you have an error
showing up here under list and also
underneath arraylist depending on how
you did your install you might have to
go ahead and import those your arraylist
from your Java utility not a big deal
and then once we go ahead and we have
this all set up
you'll see here the compiler goes
through and then we have the name of the
customer City and then it just lists the
customers going down here
so when we talk about our relationship
of our fruit smoothies franchise and
customers the customers they are a
relationship directly to the French
smoothies franchise
now the second idea is it has a relation
and let's go ahead and take a look at
that and see how that differs
and we'll go ahead and create a um oh
let's see we had customers so let's do
um
and we'll call this one
um we're doing the smoothies so we'll
have
flavors our favorite we'll do favorite
flavors favorite
flavors for a class very strange class
and the Sea and favorite flavors we'll
go ahead and give it a couple things to
look at we'll have a private
string and a name
and then we'll have a public
string
um
get flavor
there we go and that's just going to
return
we'll just have that return the name of
the flavor
there we go and then we want to go ahead
and create
one more class and this class will call
um has a relation
and I'm hoping you're guessing where
we're going with this let's go and put
some code in here to make it work
and let's go back to our favorite
flavors and put in a Constructor so that
we can load the flavors and then return
uh this name so we can return the
flavors we'll go back into hazard
relation
and let's just create a customer we'll
call it cust
uh our new customers Toby Marshall from
Mumbai and our favorite flavors are
strawberry banana and peanut butter I
don't know it's a strange concoction
and then we run a print line we're going
to print the customer name from
customers and the flavors get flavor
and so when we're looking at this what I
want you to be aware of is that neither
the flavors nor the customer are in the
same class they're not it's not an
actual relationship but they have a
relationship because we have Toby who
happens to like strawberry and peanut
butter
and if you remember just a quick note we
were looking at the diamond problem you
can create a class that then has these
two subclasses in and that's how you go
around the diamond problem is you don't
inherit but you create classes inside
the class you're working with so are you
ready to take your career to new heights
the demand for full stack web developers
is storing in today's fast-paced world
and now simple learn presence the
perfect opportunity for you to excel in
this exciting field without post
graduate program in full stack web
development this comprehensive program
will equip you with the foundation to
build full stack web applications using
the power of Java programming language
from the basics of JavaScript to
advanced level Concepts like angular
spring boot hibernate jsps and MVC we
have got you covered what else can you
expect from this program this program
includes Caltech ctme postgraduate
certificate enrollment in simply months
job assist receive up 25 CEUs from
Caltech ctme simply learns job assist
help you get noticed by the top hiring
companies you'll also get to attend
master classes from Caltech ctme
instructors live virtual classes led by
industry experts Hands-On projects and
integrated Labs online convocation by
ctme program director 20 lesson and 5
phase and project what is polymorphism
according to chemistry the term
polymorphism can be defined as the
ability of any element or compound to
exist in multiple crystalline forms this
is called polymorphism for example if
you have the carbon atom you can come
out in different forms in Coal graphite
and diamond
what is polymorphism in Java similarly
in the terms of Java programming
language polymorphism is defined as the
ability of any object in class in a
class to perform a particular task in
multiple methods this is known as
polymorphism in Java we're going to open
up our Eclipse editor and we're going to
do some animal sounds with cows cats and
dogs just kind of a fun homeless kids
like example a polymorphism and you can
see I already have my inheritance in
here let's go ahead and create a new
package and we'll call this polymorphism
just to keep it simple
and once we have our polymorphism in
there we're going to go ahead and add a
class in
and if you were doing
um an abstract class we could live with
those abstracts we're not going to
directly access it and we'll call it
animal sounds maybe we will we'll see
how we load the program up but we'll
call this animal sounds
and let's create a public it's not going
to return anything but we'll call it
sound
on here and we just want to go ahead and
have it do a system out print
and with our system out print line we'll
just have it say animals make
different sounds
there we go
so yeah it's really simple and
straightforward we're just gonna have it
print something out and if we're going
to do that let's go ahead and just a
good thing I didn't make it abstract
let's go ahead and just test it out and
see what it looks like and we'll do oh
we'll call it animal Main Animal Main
and in here let's go ahead and test out
what we just put together uh we'll do
our our static void main so it's going
to run on here and we'll create our
animal
sounds
we'll call it animal because we don't
know what kind of animal this is we'll
call it new animal
sounds
and we'll just take that animal and I
like to
put in capitalize but usually we do this
lower case there we go
and we'll just have our
animal
Dot
sound
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what comes out
we can see here animals make different
sounds okay that's not too exciting uh
so let's jump in there and let's say we
have in this case we're going to add in
a couple of different animals We'll add
in a
oh let's start with a cow you know why
not a cow
so we'll have our cow in here we'll go
ahead and click ok
and now we have our cow class but a cow
doesn't just it makes different noises
but it actually uh makes this you know a
very clear noise so we'll go ahead and
give the cow a sound
and we'll have the cow say moo moo and
the cow is going to
extend
there's our
and we'll put in our extends animal
sounds and then I want to go back here
to our animal Main
and now we have a class cow so in our
animal main we want to do a cow
equals new
cow
and once we've created the new cow we
also need to go ahead and have the cow
sounds
there we go
and we run this
you can see it comes out here and it
says the cow says moo moo so if we go
back to Cal we're just going to do this
real quick and let's say we just take
this out of here the public void sound
and then we're going to go into our
animal Main and run that
recompiles animals make different sounds
because it doesn't know what sound a cow
makes
so this is really Central to
polymorphism is we're taking something
going on in the um
in one setup that we've brought in and
extended from our animal sounds and
we've changed it to the cow says moo moo
and we can also add in multiple animals
in here we'll go ahead and just add in
one more animal I will call this one
we'll do a dog why not
uh so here comes in our dog
and of course we want the dog to
actually say something
and we'll have the dog go Bow Wow and
then we'll go back to our animal main we
have to create a dog
and we'll say cow
simply dog dog uppercase for the class
lowercase for the actual object
and then of course we need the dog to
make a sound so we'll go down here and
go dog Dot
sound
and when we run this as you expect the
it's going to compile it there we go
animals make a different sound the cow
says moo moo the dog says Bow Wow
characteristics of polymorphism the
functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior of a method is dependent on the
data polymorphism is mainly used to
implement inheritance as we saw we did
the extends with the animal sounds
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance it allows same name for a
member method in a class with different
types which will cover briefly in a
minute polymorphism supports implicit
type conversion
types of polymorphism there are
basically two types of polymorphism that
can be occurred in Java programming
language they are mentioned as follows
compile time polymorphism runtime
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time thus
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time in method overloading in Java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared we'll now execute
a program based on the functionality of
additional operator in a different
situation and let's flip back on over to
our Eclipse so in here I'm going to go
back under the dog and let me just
highlight this and we're going to do the
same thing so you see right here it says
public void sound so this is identical
public void sound but instead of sending
uh nothing we're going to send it a
string we're going to call it Angry now
at this point you should note that what
if it's a happy dog I would have to add
an if then if the string angry said
happy then we'd print happy or something
else but we're just keeping it simple so
we've entered another sound identical to
the first but we've added string angry
to it and this is going to print out the
dog says growl growl now if we go back
to our animal Main
and here's our dog same dog
same sound
but now we're going to add a string in
here
and we put that string in here we'll go
ahead and just call it Angry it doesn't
really matter what string you put in
here because we haven't sorted out what
the string means for now it just says
growl growl it's going to recompile it
so remember this is a polymorphism
during compile time and here we have it
the dog says growl growl so Doug says
Bow Wow and then the angry dog says
growl growl so there's another thing
called Operator overloading Operator
overloading is not supported in Java the
authors of java wanted to keep the
language less complicated
explaining operator overloading it
basically is a way of bundling
operations into the call statement and
user procedures it's so that it looks
like a math on a paper you have a plus
add B plus C kind of thing and it's all
wrapped up in your call to another
statement this just gets confusing it
really isn't necessary so the Java
developers decided not to put it in
there so runtime polymorphism in Java
programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage here the
overwriting method gets resolved in
execution
so far we've talked about compile time
polymorphism as you saw in the program
we just wrote when it's compiling it
does the extend and figures out which
overload method to use on there in
runtime polymorphism method overriding
in Java the method overriding is a
procedure where trial class is allowed
to implement a specific class that is
already provided in the parent class
for runtime compilation code or
polymorphism we need to go and introduce
the super keyword now from inheritance
you should remember that we can look at
Super from before but we're going to use
it slightly different it's kind of doing
the same thing as when we did The
Inheritance but we're doing like what
they call an override during run time so
the term super is predefined keyword in
Java that is used to refer the immediate
parent class object or method you find
in the program in this procedure
whenever you create an instance of
subclass then automatically an instance
of parent classes also created that will
be implicitly referred by the super
reference variable so going back into
our animal sounds let's go in here to
dog
and if we add a super Dot sound
in here this is going to reference
whatever our extend is because we
extends the dog extends animal sounds
and so here's our super dot sound and if
we go ahead and apple run and compile
this
and you can see here that it comes down
and says the dog says growl growl
because that's what we had it system out
print line two and then the super
animals make different sounds and so if
we go back to our animal main this is
what it's calling right here it's going
back into sound under the animal Mains
and it's printing out or doing whatever
it does here at this point we usually
have it returned something so you can
look up whatever the original class was
using
so getting back to these two setups
whether you're using the super to use a
runtime polymorphism because that's
what's happening during run time versus
compile time polymorphism during compile
time polymorphism method call is handled
by the compiler itself so the program
maybe take a second more to compile but
it runs faster in the run time the
method call cannot be handled by
compiler in the execution stage so if
you have any errors it's not going to
show up either during the compile time
we have compile time polymorphism is
less flexible as it needs handle all
method calls in compile time so you
really in runtime polymorphism your it
exhibits higher flexibility as the
method call gets handled at runtime
coming in the execution period for
compile time polymorphism is less that's
what I was just talking about it
compiles it so the compiling takes maybe
a little bit more but if you're
executing the same program over and over
and over again once it's distributed
it's going to run faster
then of course with the runtime
polymorphism the execution period for
runtime polymorphism takes longer it's
just a little bit more usually in most
programs you don't notice this but if
you're executing the same script A
Thousand Times suddenly that 0.01 second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
Thousand iterations uh then with the
compile time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in runtime integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in runtime again it's another delay
because it has to figure out what it's
doing it's not already pre-mapped out
and finally compile time polymorphism
occurs during method overloading and
operator overloading where runtime
polymorphism occurs during the method
overriding advantages of polymorphism
programmers code can be reused via
polymorphism number one goal of a
programmer is to reuse the code as much
as possible so you're not Reinventing
the will over and over again foreign
advantages of polymorphism supports
single variable name for multiple data
types reduces coupling between different
functionalities
and some of the disadvantages of
polymorphism that can come up is that
polymorphism ends up raising performance
issues in real time you can see whereas
you're loading all these different
things you might end up creating Loops
you didn't know you were doing
polymorphism reduces readability of the
code sometimes your actual code
everything you look at in Java is
polymorphism all based on a primary
object so you could have a very
complicated setup and then it actually
is very easy to read when you actually
put your final variable in there but
when you're going through lines and
lines of code it can be really hard to
figure out what's going on as you Loop
through all these different inherited
modules or classes programmers find
polymorphism difficult to implement just
depends the more you use it the easier
it is example we are going to have a
look at a calculator application
and this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so let's see how do we build
that app so in front of me right now is
open the main class so I have a main app
class here which has a public static
void main method and the first thing we
see is a read input class which is
calling a read method so if you go to
the read input class it has a simple
static method here which is the read
method and it is using the scanner class
if you remember I talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user so we initialize the scanner class
and we start taking the inputs and
whatever the user inputs in terms of the
expression let's say the user entered
four plus five or whatever that whole
expression gets sent back into this
input line as a string and that comes
back here in that input expression once
we have captured the input expression
the next thing we do is divide the input
expression in the numbers and The
Operators basically an expression would
be either something like
4 plus 5 into 3
divided by 2 let's say let's say the
user entered this expression so this has
either numbers or operators so that's
what we are doing here we are using the
split method of the string API the
string class basically and this split
method is going to split the numbers and
operators into two different string
arrays and here I am providing the split
expression that split at every time you
encounter one of these symbols so this
when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array which will be created
based on this expression so you will get
an array with 4 5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the operator array you
are going to split or pick out the
elements every time you receive a number
so this operator array is going to hold
this plus sign this multiply sign and
this divide sign hope you get the
understanding that we are just splitting
the whole expression into two different
arrays where first array is holding only
the numbers and no mathematical
expressions and second array is just
holding the mathematical operators and
no numbers and we'll see why we need to
do that in the upcoming lines once I
have created this string array I just
want to store or convert these string
arrays into a queue so I convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list and then I'm going to
convert this normal list into a linked
list and then going to store this linked
list into the queue of numbers and I am
going to do exactly the same thing for
the operator array as well converting
this into a generic list converting that
generic list into a linked list and then
storing this linked list as a queue so I
have an operator's queue and I have a
numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now and then I am
using the poll method if you remember
the poll method of the queue is used
when you want to fetch the first front
element the head element of the queue so
whichever element is sitting at the head
of the queue will be taken out the
moment you call call the pole method so
I fetch the first number from the
numbers queue so in this case 4 will be
fetched here in this variable and after
that I run a loop on the numbers queue
and I'm going to run this particular
Loop till this particular queue is not
empty if you see there's a negation here
so I'm going to pick up numbers one by
one from this numbers queue till the
number Q becomes empty and in inside the
loop I do this exact same pull operation
for the operation skew so this
operations queue is holding all these
mathematical operations like plus star
and divide so I'm going to pick the head
of it so in this case plus will be
picked up and will be stored in this
variable called opr and then I am going
to run a switch case on this opr
basically as I told you in this
particular calculator application we are
supporting four operations which are
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so I Define a case for each of
the mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here and for each case I'm
initializing a class if it's a plus sign
then I'm initializing the add class if
it's a minus sign then I'm initializing
the subtractors for multiplication I
have a class called multiply and for
division I have a class called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing so if I go to the add
class first of all it is implementing an
interface called operate and this
operate interface has just a single
method called get results which is
accepting a variable argument array if
you remember I told you that you can
also use a where ARG array this is
called a ARG expression this means that
this numbers will be an array of
arbitrary length it can be a one element
array it can be a two element array it
can be a Four Element array or whatever
you supply but it is still going to be a
fixed length array but the length is
going to be dependent upon how much
argument you supply to this particular
method so that is what this interface
operate is doing is it just has one
method declared which is called get
result which is accepting an array of
numbers so if the ad class is
implementing the operate interface then
it has to override the get result method
and here it is just doing a summation of
all the numbers which have been supplied
so if you supply four numbers it is just
going to add up those four numbers and
return the sum and the exact same kind
of logic or similar logic will be seen
in other operate classes so if I go to
the subtract class it runs the exact
same operation but it subtracts the
values if I go to the multiply class it
is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the Divide class it is also
implementing the operating interface and
it is dividing all the numbers one by
one so it's doing pretty much the same
thing in terms of the expression and the
logic the only difference is whether you
are using an add operation or a subtract
or multiply or a divide so we have
checked all these classes and the
operating interface as well and let's go
back to the main app now now you also
see that I've defined a reference of
operate here and each of the switch case
block I am assigning the object type to
this interface reference so I'm using
the concept of dynamic binding which we
talked about when we talked about
interfaces that we can also do Dynamic
binding where we can assign an object to
an interface type and the object type
will depend upon the expression so once
we have filled that based on the case
while filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially then we go to the next line
of outside the switch case block which
is to pick the next number from the
queue remember we already did one poll
here so as per this example 4 was here
in this race and now when we do this
number dot pull again 5 will be picked
up because that will be the next head of
the queue so we pick up 5 here and then
we call operate Dot get result now this
get result will be called based on the
expression which was encountered first
in the queue again looking at the
example the first expression encountered
will be plus so the expression was plus
so the operator type object is of add
type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked and it is going to
Sum 4 and 5. this rest is holding 4
right now based on what I described here
numbers dot pole and this num is holding
the the second operand basically
basically five here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case and then it
again goes back here and it checks if
the number Q is now empty no it is still
not empty because we still have 3 and 2
left there so that again it does the
operations dot pole and it picks up
multiply sign here then it again runs
the switch case since it's a multiply
sign it will go here and it will
initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class then coming here it will do a
numbers dot pole and this time the
numbers dot pole is going to pick up
three so three will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9 4 plus 5 was 9 the
current value of result will be updated
here so rest will be 9 here and num will
be 3 here and when you call operate dot
get result the multiply classes get
result will get called and it will say 9
into 3 which will become 27 it will
again go back here to this particular
line and it will check again if the
numbers queue is now empty no it is
still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls uh the queue of the
operations where the expression divide
is present there which is the only
element left in this particular
operations queue and since we have the
opr value as divide this case block gets
called and the New Divide class gets
initialized the Divide class basically
gets initialized and we come here and we
do numbers dot Pole now the last number
which is available in this queue is 2
which gets picked up here and then we
again call operate dot get result this
times is the operate object refer object
operate reference type was of divide
class type so when we call operate dot
get result The Divide operation or the
get result method of the Divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and it will divide the current value of
result which was 4 plus 5 9 into 3 which
was 27 so it is going to divide 27 by 2
which was the last value of the foreign
so it is it is going to execute 27 by 2
and whatever value it gets it is going
to store the value back into the rest
variable and then it is again going to
go back here and again going to check
the condition if the numbers Q is not
empty but now the numbers queue is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result that is
how this whole program is working now
let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if I right click and go to run as and
run this as Java application and I
Supply an expression saying 4 plus 5
Star 3 divide 2 and if I now hit enter I
get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9 then 9 into 3 will be 27
and 27 divided by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues and once we have those queues
built up then we pick up the first
number and we keep running this Loop
till the numbers Q is not empty inside
the while loop at each step we pick up
the first expression or the operator we
check what is the operator whether it is
an addition subtraction multiplication
or division operator and whatever kind
of operator we have we initialize the
corresponding class of it and then we
fetch the next value in the numbers
queue and then we call the get result
based on the expression and whatever
result we get from the get result we
store it back into the rest variable so
we keep updating the rest variable at
every step that's the reason the result
of 4 plus 5 gets stored in the rest and
next time you are calling the get result
for a multiply operation here the rest
value is 9 now and it says 9 into 3.
again in the next time the rest value
will be updated to 27 because we are
storing the result back into the result
variable
so this is all I want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lots more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs Etc also looking
at putting some conditions around the
exception handling handling the divide
by zero scenario Etc which is not here
but this is just to show you the basic
idea of how you can build simple to
complex CLI applications using the core
Java Concepts well that's a wrap on the
basics of Java programming we hope you
found this video informative and helpful
bye now you should understand the most
basic concept of Java programming and
the reasons to master this programming
language in 2023 if you are interested
in learning more about different
Technologies plenty of resources are
available at simply load you can also
check out our website for more
information on different certifications
thank you for watching and we'll see you
next time until then keep learning and
stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here